ne sont plus attendre je vais commencer
cette table ronde qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre des travaux de notre commission
spéciale qui est une commission
transversale au Sénat qui concerne
l'ensemble de commissions qui a été mise
en place pour
étudier le texte qui nous est soumis
réguler sécurisé l'espace numérique donc
un texte dont nous débattrons début
juillet dans dans l'hémicycle apex pour
lequel nous avons fait des travaux déjà
au sein de la commission des affaires
européennes puisque il s'agit d'un texte
d'application de règlement
européen
bien entendu je pense au DMA au DSA au
data govenens actes et aussi le Data
acte qui est encore en cours de de
discussions et qui pourtant est anticipé
quelque peu dans dans le texte comme on
peut
le voir alors donc je vous accueille
donc et je vous cite donc Monsieur
Arnaud David utilisateurs des affaires
publiques européennes d'Amazon Monsieur
Benoît tabacca
depuis longtemps au Sénat secrétaire
général de Google France et Frédéric
Géraud directeur des politiques
publiques de Google cloud France qui
vous
accompagne
pardonnez-moi parce que je cherche
monsieur Anton Marie et à patesti
directeur des politiques publiques et
madame Béatrice Ouvrard responsable et
c'est faire public de méta France c'est
vrai que c'est des plus Facebook
maintenant et c'est
beta qui regroupe d'ailleurs d'autres
au final que que Facebook alors avec les
rapporteurs donc Louis kervé et Patrick
Chaize on va vous poser un certain
nombre de questions ainsi que l'ensemble
des collègues qui sont ici présents ce
qu'on peut dire en introduction c'est
que les entreprises que vous représentez
sont très importantes les qualifie de
Big tech le plus souvent et elle repose
sur un modèle économique qui a été
qualifié d'ailleurs par une célèbre
professeur de Harvard que tous connaître
qui s'appelle sochalas qui est a dit ces
entreprises reposent sur le modèle du
capitalisme de surveillance qui est un
modèle qui n'est pas sans poser problème
aux Européens
vous ne découvrirez rien dans ce que
j'annonce et du coup d'un régime de
non-revettes redevabilité non
responsabilités qui étaient établie par
la directive e-commerce on va passer à
un autre type de régime qui vise à
réguler les grandes plateformes que vous
êtes tant pour le marché
numérique tout le domaine économique que
pour celui des offres de services qui
concernent plutôt les les usages il
s'agit du du DSA
la question des données au centre en
réalité de la problématique qui qui nous
réunit et les textes d'ailleurs
apportent un certain nombre de de
solutions pour mieux protéger la vie
privée mieux l'encadrer aussi les
intérêts stratégiques que ça peut
représenter pour l'Europe mais l'idée
aussi des textes c'est de remettre une
concurrence plus loyale entre
entreprises c'est aussi permettre
de rééquilibrer un système qui est très
fortement
anti-concurrentiel à votre bénéfice il
faut bien le dire et on est dans un
système qui est extrêmement verrouillé
d'un point de vue juridique financier et
technique donc les textes sont faits
aussi pour apporter un certain nombre de
de réponses sont fait aussi pour
répondre je pense notamment à
l'application du DSA à tous les effets
toxiques et finalement pervers de du
modèle économique des plateformes encore
une fois il y a des faiblesses qui
permettent des comment dire des mes
usages tels que la désinformation la
manipulation de la formation les
surexposition des contenus pénombre
pédoporno Afrique les phénomènes de
harcèlement de n en ligne sans
régulation on voit bien que tout ça est
devenu une jungle et qu'il faut pouvoir
travailler à retrouver de la confiance
en tout cas des des meilleurs
usages dans le cadre d'un modèle qui est
redoutablement il faut bien dire
addictique et efficace il faut aussi
l'admettre voilà j'ai dressé un petit
peu le tableau mais ce sont des constats
que vous connaissez on invente rien le
Sénat est très attaché à ces questions
nos gros travaux l'ont montré de de
longues dates donc nous notre idée c'est
de voir comment sera appliqué
le dessin cliquerez vous d'ailleurs bien
le DSA et le DMA d'ici quelques mois et
voir comment vous pouvez de votre côté à
travers les propositions qui sont faites
et bien contribuer à ce qui est une
meilleure régulation d'un monde pour
lequel les usagers ont besoin d'avoir
confiance ils ont besoin d'avoir
confiance en seconde voilà donc je vous
souhaite la parole peut-être
successivement pour 5 minutes chacun et
puis après on laissera les rapporteurs
vous posez les questions qui convient
alors par qui commence t-on
monsieur Batesti vous souhaitez vous
lancer ou madame vrard merci pour votre
invitation et merci pour ce résumé
madame la Présidente alors pour meta
s'avérer de on n'est pas un service
cloud précisé d'ores et déjà parce qu'on
voit qu'il y a pas mal de discussions
sur la partie cloud donc on va se
cantonner sur la partie plateforme nous
il y a trois éléments on en a déjà parlé
tout à l'heure avec Monsieur Hervé le
rapporteur Monsieur Hervé un la
prétransposition comme vous le signifier
madame Morin deci sur la partie de
certains textes qui ne sont pas encore
votés au niveau européen qui sont encore
en cours de discussion tels que les
hayaks mais aussi Sam sur la partie
protection et contenu pédopornographie
mais également la partie
d'attaque on alerte juste sur le fait
qu'il y a certains articles qui ont été
notifiés mais pas tous auprès de la
Commission on s'interroge
particulièrement sur l'article 16
relatif au pérennes pourquoi il n'a pas
été notifié alors qu'il fait référence
aux articles 40 et 34 de mémoire du DSA
donc si on pouvait avoir un
éclaircissement sur cette partie là ça
serait intéressant et l'autre partie
c'est qui nous intéresse
particulièrement ça va être sur la
partie cyber-harcèlement comme vous le
savez on développe depuis de nombreuses
années des outils à disposition de nos
utilisateurs pour
diminuer et les effets de harcèlement
qui peut arriver sur les plateformes on
voit qu'il y a une un système qui est
proposé qui est assez intéressant de
mettre une à partir du moment où les
personnes sont condamnées une
responsabilité effectivement pour les
condamnés de ne plus être sur les
réseaux sociaux de 6 mois et en cas de
récidive de un an avec après en revanche
une disposition qui nous questionne sur
la partie nouveau compte créé où là
c'est comment on identifie ces nouveaux
comptes qui nous les notifie et si ça il
s'agit de personnes condamnées il
s'agirait donc aussi d'un fichier de
personnes sensibles parce que c'est des
inscriptions quasi judiciaires donc
comment cela peut prendre forme
ce qu'on a déjà proposé discuter tout à
l'heure ce qui nous semble intéressant
c'est peut-être mettre quelque chose
d'intermédiaire avant le judiciaire et
pourquoi pas utiliser la plateforme
farousse le cfctic qui sont des agents
assermentés et donc qui ont pouvoir
aussi aujourd'hui qui traitent pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée pour meta en
France et plus de 25000 réquisitions
uniquement pour la France par année
pourquoi ne pas utiliser farros pour
aussi avoir un système de contraventions
intermédiaire pour justement endiguer
ces phénomènes et que tout ne passe pas
aux judiciaires où on sait des
traitements et la durée va pouvoir être
aussi plus longue et donc répondre à ces
attentes là aussi auprès des
utilisateurs
sur la troisième et dernière partie je
vais laisser la parole à un tonne
oui juste un commentaire qui concerne
les questions d'âge qui sont traitées
dans ce PJL via l'accès au site
pornographique un point d'alerte
peut-être pour rappeler un évitement de
fractionnement de législation puisqu'à
par ailleurs en parallèle une PPL portée
par le député monsieur Marc Angeli donc
vous avez sûrement entendu parler
qui concerne la majorité numérique donc
la première chose serait peut-être
d'essayer de réconcilier ces questions
via le PGA le gouvernemental l'autre
point concerne aussi donc sa cohérence
ces questions d'âge avec les questions
d'âge posées par le DSA donc le
fractionnement européen ici interroge
véritablement puisque la commission via
son code de conduite sur
en prenant glycismes chicty c'est saisi
de ces sujets donc la France pourrait
bien sûr être moteur de ces sujets mais
une loi nationale sur ces domaines sans
solution de technique évidentes semble
aujourd'hui
interroger les acteurs et donc il
convient qu'on se met plutôt tous autour
de la table opérateur de télécom
fournisseur de service d'exploitation de
magasins d'applications mais aussi bien
sûr plateforme pour essayer en fin
d'adresser ses points donc je crois que
le gouvernement il travaille je crois
qu'il y a eu des propositions donc
espérons qu'on puisse avancer aussi sur
ce sujet dans le cas de ce PJL parce que
c'est évidemment très important merci
monsieur tabaca oui merci beaucoup
madame la Présidente messieurs les
rapporteur mesdames et messieurs et les
sénateurs vous avez raison au début
quand vous avez rappelé effectivement
l'historique de la régulation du
numérique et je pense qu'effectivement
le projet de loi et bien en quelque
sorte par achevé tout le travail qui a
été engagé depuis quasiment 20 ans de
repenser cette régulation puisqu'on va
transposer et vous l'avez rappelé les
deux textes européens en matière de
régulation on va changer effectivement
un certain nombre de choses dans
l'ordonnancement juridique et nous on a
vu effectivement au cours des dernières
années notamment les différents textes
qui avaient été adoptés que ça soit la
lutte sur la désinformation que ça soit
en matière de renforcement l'année de
contre la haine ce qui a été intéressant
pour nous c'était pour la première fois
on avait quelqu'un à qui parler qui
était un régulateur un interlocuteur on
avait commencé effectivement ce travail
avec l'arcom on espère qu'il se
poursuivra même après le l'adoption
l'adoption et l'entrée en vigueur plus
exactement du DSA et pour nous voilà ça
représente un élément important si je
viens spécifiquement sur sur le projet
de loi la partie sur la transposition du
DSA du DMA pour invocacher on a encore
en train de regarder ce que ça
correspond effectivement au texte en
termes de symétrie le soleil élément
qu'on a aujourd'hui identifié c'est une
question de date avec potentiellement
une entrée en vigueur ou plus exactement
l'entrée en vigueur du nouveau cadre
juridique français qui viendrait
postérieurement à l'entrée en vigueur du
cadre européen donc il y aurait un
moment où en tout cas pour les grandes
plateformes les deux cadres juridiques
européens français c'est superposerait
mais disons c'est plus une question de
de détails en termes de de de date dans
le dans le texte mais on continue à
expertiser ça sur la partie classe je
laisserai Frédéric vous répondre et
apporter des éléments avec l'étiquette
Google cloud nous en fait les points
intéressants et sur lequel on travaille
spécifiquement et notamment au cours des
des deux auditions précédentes c'est
effectivement la question de la lutte
contre les arnaques et de voir comment
se dis dispositif qui est intéressant
peut aussi être amélioré et vous l'avez
précisé madame présidente l'idée c'est
de travailler une meilleure régulation
on y a énormément de briques aujourd'hui
dans le texte que ça soit en matière de
filtre entièrement que ça soit en
matière de protection de l'enfance que
ce soit également par exemple sur les
premiers dispositifs concernant
la vérification d'âge le contrôle par
l'arcom qui pourrait sans doute être un
peu amélioré en termes d'efficacité
notamment en allant un petit peu plus
loin dans dans ces textes là pour vous
donner quelques éléments effectivement
si on pense à la question du du filtre
anti-arnac on peut essayer de regarder
comment on arrive à intégrer notamment
le système
j'adhère de créer une sorte de canal de
communication de ne pas avoir des
multiples autorités qui viennent
signaler tel ou tel site comme étant
potentiellement des arnaques on pourrait
aussi imaginer aligner le mécanisation
avec celui sur le dessin vous savez avec
ces défa systémique le concept que
reprend notamment le DSA un des éléments
aussi qu'on peut se poser la question
pour en reparler si ça vous intéresse
c'est de se dire le filtre anti-narnac
aujourd'hui est mis en oeuvre
principalement par différents acteurs
mais par exemple ça mesure là ne
concerne pas les opérateurs alors que ce
sont le premier canal dans lequel
l'arnaque viendra et on pourrait
imaginer avec les mêmes systèmes de
d'affichage de pages comme aujourd'hui
le fond dans différents secteurs de
faire en sorte que les opérateurs aussi
participent collectivement à ce blocage
ou du moins cette information prélevable
des utilisateurs et c'est intéressant de
se dire est-ce que comme on parlait tout
à l'heure d'efficacité est-ce qu'on peut
pas améliorer cette efficacité autre
exemple aussi c'est sur la partie sur la
lutte contre les cyber-harcèlement oui
effectivement
on a aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui existent je pense que le
dispositif prévu par la loi pareil va
dans le bon sens la question c'est qu'il
arrivera sans doute il sera mis en
oeuvre tard il faut savoir aujourd'hui
c'était chez
très riche je crois que c'est 54
personnes qui sont poursuivies en France
chaque année en matière de lutte contre
cyber-harcèlement quelquefois plusieurs
années après les mesures on a besoin de
prendre les plus rapidement possible
donc avoir une mesure de blocage de
compte qui intervient plusieurs années
après la commission de l'infraction on
peut l'imaginer mais ça veut dire que
pendant trois quatre ans la personne qui
sera déclarée coupable va poursuivre ses
agissements donc la question c'est de se
dire est-ce qu'on est capable de faire
remonter le travail judiciaire un peu
plus tôt et notamment prendre l'exemple
qui a été fait en matière
contraventionnelle pour les amendes pour
du harcèlement de rue aujourd'hui on est
capable de mettre une amende à une
personne lorsqu'elle fait du harcèlement
de rue dans les heures qui suivent on
n'est pas capable de le mettre sur
internet c'est un peu la question qu'il
faut se poser peut-être sur lesquels on
peut travailler je m'arrête là mais on
pourra aborder d'autres sujets et je
passe la parole à Frédéric
alors dire que certains d'entre vous ont
l'activité informatique en nuage voilà
donc de stockage de traitement de la
donnée vous n'êtes pas que des réseaux
sociaux merci beaucoup madame la
Présidente merci à la commission assez
rapporteurs et au sénateurs présents de
nous avoir invités
je pense utile et important de préciser
que Google Cloud est l'un des derniers
entrants sur le marché de l'informatique
en nuages que nous sommes souvent cités
dans la presse comme 5ème acteur du
marché de l'informatique en nuage en
France avec moins de 10% de parts de
marché loin derrière Amazon et Microsoft
et moins loin de VH Cloud et d'orange
par construction compte tenu de cette
position de challenger par donner moi ce
mot nous sommes favorables à toute
action qui puisse fluidifier le marché
un marché qui est toujours vous l'avez
souligné madame le Président en
expansion notamment en France où
l'adoption des technologies en nuage se
fait plus lentement que dans le reste de
l'Union européenne
nous sommes donc toujours surpris d'être
associés aux deux leaders du marché
comme dans la première question du
questionnaire qui nous avait été proposé
pour l'audition du jour chez Google
cloud nous croyons en un nuage qui tient
sa promesse initiale ouverture et
sécurité élasticité et simplicité et
surtout une grande liberté de choix pour
le client notamment pour tester de
nouvelles fonctionnalités innovations
Google cloud souhaite donc se
différencier des autres acteurs
notamment grâce à ses services basés sur
des technologies Open Source ces
technologies étant la pierre angulaire
de l'interopérabilité on y reviendra de
la portabilité d'une meilleure
utilisation aussi des ressources
énergétiques et de l'indépendance de ces
fournisseurs Google Cloud est d'ailleurs
l'un des premiers fournisseurs à s'être
mis volontairement en conformité avec le
code européen dénommé swipo pour
promouvoir la portabilité et la liberté
de changer de fournisseur ce qui n'est
pas le cas de tous les acteurs du marché
Google Cloud est reconnu pour être un
acteur majeur du monde de l'open source
nous remettons régulièrement des
technologies à fort impact entre les
mains de la communauté open source
mondiale notamment des logiciels comme
kubernetti système sur flow qui sont
aujourd'hui utilisés par d'autres y
compris nos concurrents directs chez
Google cloud nous avons toujours eu
comme mantrack nous ne sommes ni les
meilleurs ni les plus parfaits mais que
nous sommes sérieux fiables pragmatiques
et surtout que nous allons toujours
quelque chose à apprendre de nos
partenaires et interlocuteurs notamment
ici aujourd'hui comme nous apprenons
tous les jours de notre principal
partenaire en France le groupe Thalès
avec qui nous travaillons une offre
portée par sens la filiale cloud de
Thalès et qui a pour vocation de
décrocher la qualification 5N cloud
notre vision d'un cloud de confiance
passe donc par des technologies Open
Source garantes de sécurité de
maintenance à long terme et donc d'une
plus grande robustesse pour les
utilisateurs finaux ce propos
introductif portera donc sur le titre 3
et du projet de loi et notamment ces
deux premiers chapitres consacrés à
l'informatique en nuage
qu'elle ne fut pas notre plaisir madame
la Présidente de lire dans le titre
de ce chapitre pratique commerciale
déloyal entre entreprises sur le marché
de l'informatique en nuage car de notre
point de vue et nous l'avons exprimé
déjà auprès de l'Autorité de la
concurrence française il existe des
pratiques commerciales que nous
souhaitons voir qualifier de déloya
Google clouds souligner ici la grande
qualité des travaux portés par le sigref
en France et par le suspect au niveau
européen et leurs 10 principes pour
l'octroi de licence logicielle équitable
pour les clients utilisant
l'informatique en nuage je précise que
Google n'est membre d'aucune de ces deux
organisations nous attendons aussi vous
le savez prochainement le travail de
l'Autorité de la concurrence qui devrait
utilement nourrir ce débat qu'elle ne
fut donc pas notre surprise de ne pas
trouver dans ce chapitre 1 le résultat
des travaux du sigref et du 6play mais
d'y trouver le sujet des avoirs ou
crédits cloud alors même que nombre
d'autorités de la concurrence notamment
française britannique mais j'ai entendu
dans trop d'autres auditions
néerlandaises ou japonaises
[Musique]
il y a aussi la définition au combien
crucial de l'équivalence fonctionnelle
qui nous paraît aujourd'hui différente
des travaux européens un sujet fort
complexe qui nécessite à nos yeux
beaucoup là encore de pragmatisme
concernant les nouveaux pouvoirs confiés
à la recette en matière
d'interopérabilité nous sommes forts
reconnus dans ce domaine et seront ravis
de travailler avec l'autorité et sa
présidence nous croyons donc le nous
croyons dans le pragmatisme de
l'autorité et somme plutôt dubitatif sur
l'opportunité de créer une norme
française dans la matière en effet les
normes internationales ont fait leur
preuve sur le marché des
télécommunications et de l'Internet
depuis quelques années déjà en
conclusion madame la Présidente cher
rapporteur cher parlementaire chers
administrateurs
nous souhaitons apporter avec joie notre
contribution à vos travaux notamment
vous l'aurez compris sur les licences
logicielles équitables et un marché de
l'informatique en nuage toujours plus
ouvert merci beaucoup merci donc je
donne la parole au présentant d'Amazon
dans la même configuration que que nos
voisins puisque mon collègue Arnaud
David interviendra sur les questions de
d'informatique en nuage pour ma part je
voulais
profiter de l'occasion qui m'est donnée
je vous en remercie pour essayer
d'inscrire le texte que vous allez
examiner dans un contexte un peu plus
large qui est celui de l'ambition auquel
il répond cette ambition c'est une
ambition qui a été inscrite dans la
stratégie numérique européenne en 2015
et qui consiste à construire le marché
unique du numérique c'est très
clairement expliqué dans cette stratégie
européenne afin de garantir aux
consommateurs aux entreprises à un
meilleur accès au bien et au service en
ligne d'une part et d'autre part de
créer un environnement favorable à la
croissance des réseaux et des services
numériques pour faire du numérique un
moteur de croissance en Europe
et je dois dire pour commencer que
amazon est pleinement en phase avec cet
objectif que nous faisons tout à fait
notre et donc avec les objectifs
poursuivis par les pouvoirs publics on
l'a bien mesuré qui était exclusivement
en fait en faveur du consommateur voilà
et pas forcément d'une industrie
européenne je me permets de le rajouter
on a changé de braquet depuis il y a eu
des événements qui sont survenus depuis
le repas pris conscience voilà n'hésitez
pas une politique industrielle et de
souveraineté donc on est plus tout à
fait dans le même la même configuration
qu'en 2015 si je peux me permettre avec
la boussole numérique et le plan
d'action 2030 alors je vais me donner
l'occasion de dire madame la Présidente
qu'effectivement amazon a une obsession
qui est celle des consommateurs et donc
c'est à ce titre que je souhaite
intervenir justement pour rappeler
l'importance que qu'on sait texte et qui
a le marché unique européen pour les
consommateurs qu'il s'agisse de
particulier ou d'entreprises
et je voudrais dire en quelques mots que
nous contribuons et nous avons contribué
depuis près d'un quart de siècle en
Europe à la construction de ce marché
unique et de sa composante numérique
puisque lorsque nous sommes installés en
France en 2000
le marché unique venait d'être proclamé
les quatre libertés qui sont
constitutives de ce marché unique avec
été affichées mais leur mise en oeuvre
était encore très très limitée notamment
la libre circulation des biens parce que
il y avait des réseaux logistiques qui
n'étaient pas à l'échelle de l'Union
européenne n'était pas véritablement
entrée dans les mœurs dans la réalité
puis la libre circulaire libre
prestation de service elle aussi était
balbutiante puisque il y avait peu de
services en ligne fiables sur et facile
d'accès pour tous les Européens
les consommateurs et les entreprises
européen avait donc un accès au marché
unique en droit mais pas véritablement
en fait et aujourd'hui je constate que
ces libertés sont devenues des réalités
lorsque vous lorsque les consommateurs
se rendent sur Amazon ou sur les sites
équivalents dans d'autres pays européens
Amazon.fr
les consommateurs peuvent avoir accès à
des millions de produits disponibles au
sein de l'Union européenne et aux offres
pas seulement d'Amazon mais aussi de 225
000 entreprises européennes pour la
plupart des TPE et des PME dont 13
000 françaises qui utilisent Amazon pour
accéder à la clientèle européenne et qui
recouvre aussi à notre réseau logistique
pour livrer leurs produits à des
consommateurs qui sont parfois dans un
autre pays parfois qui ne parlent pas la
même langue et ça c'est une réalité qui
est importante de constater parce
qu'elle est le fruit de ce marché unique
et elle est le fruit de sa composante
numérique
et cette cette construction du marché
unique elle s'est exprimée dans d'autres
domaines avec la mise à disposition on
en parlera dans un instant de service
d'informatique en nuage qui l'a encore
permettre à des entreprises européennes
de stocker et de traiter leur donner de
manière efficace et sécurisée et puis
avec aussi les industries créatives
puisque nous avons depuis deux ans
financé par moins de 130 créations
européennes originales quand par exemple
un cinéaste tel que Cédric Klapisch fait
la suite de l'auberge espagnole qui
s'appelle salade grecque et bien cette
série est diffusée partout en Europe et
donc aide à la constitution d'un espace
culturel commun en Europe et c'est donc
un des aspects une des facettes de ce
marché unique européen et de ce marché
unique du numérique
tout ceci madame la Présidente se
traduit par de très importants
investissements amazon a investi en
Europe 142 milliards d'euros depuis 2010
dont 16 milliards d'euros rien qu'en
France et tout ceci se traduit également
par des créations d'emploi qui sont tout
à fait
significatifs puisque amazon est
l'entreprise en France qui a créé le
plus d'emplois depuis 2010 avec
aujourd'hui donc tous secteurs confondus
avec près de 100 000 emplois directs et
indirects implantés sur notre territoire
aujourd'hui et enfin un dernier mot pour
les entreprises les PME et les TPE
françaises qui utilisent Amazon je le
disais il y a un instant pour accéder à
leurs clients elles ont exporté en 2021
dernière chiffre disponible pour 600
millions d'euros via Amazon donc le
marché unique et sa présence numérique
sont donc aujourd'hui devenu des
réalités et tout ceci se fait au
bénéfice vous le disiez consommateurs
mais aussi des salariés puisqu'il y a
des créations d'emplois et des
entreprises européennes et je dois dire
nous en sommes très fiers alors la
régulation bien sûr Amazon adhère
pleinement à l'idée que ce marché doit
être régulé et pleinement aussi à l'idée
que les règles qui s'appliquent dans la
vie réelle dans le monde physique
doivent également s'appliquer en ligne
c'est déjà largement de l'endroit même
si des difficultés demeurent en pratique
et là encore nous faisons plus
qu'adhérer simplement à cette idée nous
nous mobilisons en offrant à nos clients
européens des services sûrs et en les
préservant des fraudes en ligne de la
contrefaçon de la cybercriminalité et
des contenus et comportements illégaux
l'an dernier pour vous donner quelques
chiffres nous avons bloqué plus de 800
000 tentatives de création de compte
frauduleux nous avons travaillé avec les
marques et les autorités pour signaler
ou poursuivre plus de 1300 contre
facteurs et nous avons permis de repérer
et de saisir plus de 6 millions un
produit contre fait empêchant toute
revente dans la chaîne
d'approvisionnement le résultat madame
la Présidente c'est que aujourd'hui nous
avons la confiance des Français les
études et les sondages et les enquêtes
de pignons le confirme après année après
année et cette confiance nous engage à
poursuivre dans cette voie l'an dernier
nous avons investi plus d'un milliard
d'euros dans justement
l'ensemble des actions que je citais à
l'instant pourquoi parce que nous savons
que cette confiance elle a été durement
acquise elle est longue à gagner et elle
peut être perdue très rapidement alors
pour répondre à une question que vous
posiez en introduction bien évidemment
Amazon se conformera au règlement
européen que vous vous apprêtez à
adapter en droit français même si ça
n'est pas un secret nous l'avons souvent
dit certaines de leurs disposition ne
semblent pas de nature à renforcer la
protection des Européens dans le monde
numérique
et pour conclure je voudrais attirer
aujourd'hui puisque vous apprêtez à
examiner ce texte votre attention sur
deux risques qui sont associés à
l'examen de ce texte le premier c'est un
risque de fragmentation géographique le
marché unique numérique n'est unique que
parce que les mêmes règles s'appliquent
d'un bout à l'autre de l'Europe ces
effets positifs en termes d'innovation
en termes d'investissement en termes de
création d'emplois ou en termes de
protection des citoyens et des
consommateurs européens
disparaîtrait si la transposition des
textes qui vous sont soumis ou leur
application par les jeux d'élections
nationales
aboutissaient à désolidariser la France
de ses voisins européens les
consommateurs français seraient alors
soumis à des règles et à des niveaux de
protection différents selon qu'il
choisisse d'acheter en ligne sur un site
par exemple français ou belge ce qui
n'est évidemment pas souhaitable
et le second risque sur lequel je
souhaite attirer également votre
attention et celui d'un espace numérique
à deux vitesses dans lequel certaines
règles s'appliqueraient ne
s'appliquerait qu'aux acteurs les plus
importants ce qui signifie et je reviens
en consommateur qui sont effectivement
le fil conducteur de mon propos que les
consommateurs français et européens
ne pourrait plus avoir confiance dans
tous les services qu'ils utilisent et
les produits qu'ils achètent quel que
soit la taille de l'entreprise concernée
et c'est ce point qui me parle paraître
important dans le monde physique la loi
protège de la même façon tous les
consommateurs qu'ils se rendent dans un
hypermarché ou dans un petit commerce de
centre-ville et à notre sens il devrait
en aller de même dans le monde numérique
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire et
donc nous espérons que vos débats
permettront si ce n'est d'éviter au
moins d'aplanir ces deux écueils et
contribueront à donner les mêmes droits
et les mêmes protections dans le monde
numérique et à garantir un environnement
numérique à la fois sûr et propice à
l'innovation au bénéfice des citoyens et
des acteurs académie européen
du risque de fragmentation de la
législation mais je vous rappelle cette
sont des textes de règlement n'ont pas
les directives donc déjà il y a une
harmonisation par le haut qui s'impose
donc voilà mais on a bien conscience du
sujet merci la parole à Monsieur David
maintenant merci madame la Présidente
messieurs les rapporteurs
mesdamesinatrices messieurs les sénateur
je vous remercie de donner à Amazon
webservie 6 de l'occasion d'échanger sur
ce projet de loi sur lequel j'aurai
trois remarques principales à formuler
avant ça je voudrais très brièvement
présenter notre activité qui nous sommes
ce que nous faisons Amazon Web Services
que je désignerai par l'acronyme AWS est
une entreprise d'informatique en nuage
cette année nous fêtons les cinq ans de
nos premiers centres de données en
France lorsque nous nous les avons
ouverts en 2017 nous avons
décidé d'un plan d'investissement sur 15
ans d'un montant de 6 milliards d'euros
en infrastructure aujourd'hui on compte
1000 salariés en France et l'Institut
public first considère que
AWS génère un.6 milliards d'euros de
valeur économique qui soutient 130 000
entreprises et 22
000 emplois on investit également dans
la formation pour aider les citoyens
français à acquérir des compétences
numériques que ce soit dans la sécurité
ou dans l'intelligence artificielle et
on prévoit de former
29000 personnes d'ici 2025 notre métier
on y reviendra probablement dans le dans
les questions relatives aux définitions
et de fournir des à la demande des
ressources informatiques avec une
tarification à l'usage
on fournit aujourd'hui à nos clients
français plus de 200 services qui vont
du stockage de la gestion de base de
données et de la sécurité l'intelligence
artificielle notre modèle d'affaires il
repose sur la confiance de nos clients
et on investit continuellement pour
permettre à nos clients de décider où
ils stockent leurs données comment elles
sont utilisées qui a accès et comment
elles sont sécurisées de manière
générale nous soutenons dans le dans la
perspective de la discussion le
développement d'un écosystème numérique
ouvert et compétitif pour les industries
les gouvernements les citoyens européens
en France en particulier
nous soutenons toutes les initiatives
qui consistent à aider à l'accélération
de la transition numérique des
organisations publiques et privées tout
en garantissant et sa point important
que les utilise les utilisateurs
disposent d'une entière liberté dans le
choix de la technologie qui
correspondent le mieux à leurs besoins
cette liberté de choix elle est encore
une fois fondamentale empêcher le
verrouillage des utilisateurs des
solutions d'informatique en nuages nous
semble stimuler la concurrence un point
sur aussi probablement le
l'environnement de l'informatique en
nuage en France il y a une étude de
Didier C qui indique que le nombre de
fournisseurs d'informatique en nuage à
considérablement augmenter entre 2017 et
2021 le nombre de fournisseurs de taille
moyenne c'est à dire qu'on a un chiffre
d'affaires de plus de 20 millions
d'euros est passé de 17 à 40 et ceux qui
ont un chiffre d'affaires de moins de 5
milliards d'euros donc de taille plus
plus petite de 47 à 132 donc on voit
bien le dynamisme de ce marché dans
toutes les dominantes de l'informatique
en nuage comme je disais en préambule ce
projet de loi nécessite la main
attentive de législateur et ce sur trois
points en particulier ma première
remarque c'est
sur l'opportunité de l'encadrement des
avoir proposé à l'article 7 Monsieur
Frédéric Jérôme a parlé tout à l'heure
c'est une pratique assez courante dans
nombreux secteurs au-delà du secteur du
numérique et largement répondu les pour
ce qui concerne et de l'Ouest et AWS
pardon et l'octroi de ses avoir à nos
clients il y a deux principaux objectifs
le premier c'est de permettre
d'accélérer la transition numérique des
entreprises et donc de les encourager à
utiliser ces nouveaux services et le
deuxième c'est un moyen d'expérimenter
aussi ces nouvelles technologies
notamment pour les petites moyennes
entreprises et les jeunes pousses en
tant que tel et le l'Autorité de la
concurrence la souligné dans son avis
l'avoir n'est pas une pratique
anti-concurrentielle et en l'occurrence
le supprimer ou en réduire sensiblement
sa portée pourrait entraver la french
tech comme le souligne la vie en la
privant de crédit alors que ces avoirs
seraient disponibles dans d'autres pays
européens et de manière générale se pose
la question de la nécessité d'avoir une
lettre spécialiste sans la matière là où
des sanctions en cas de pratique
concurrentiel existe que ce soit le
déséquilibre significatif ou l'avantage
sont contrepartie la deuxième remarque
concerne les frais au titre du des
transferts de données vers un nouveau
fournisseur et je tiens à préciser
aujourd'hui il me semble que Monsieur
Géraud l'a rappelé que la grande
majorité des prestataires de services
informatiques ne facturent pas de frais
supplémentaires ni de pénalité lorsqu’un
client passe d'un fournisseur à un autre
c'est très important et pour ce qui nous
concerne plus particulièrement à
WS c'est le cas il n'y a pas de
facturation de frais supplémentaires
lorsqu'un client change d'environnement
numérique ce que nous facturons c'est
l'utilisation du réseau quel que soit la
finalité le motif défini par
l'entreprise utilisatrice c'est
uniquement le fait que l'entreprise
prend les données qui sont stockées pour
en faire un usage et c'est cela que nous
facturons dans le cadre du réseau que
nous avons mis en place
par exemple lorsqu'une entreprise
diffuse du contenu que ce soit une
entreprise de services de radio
Diffusion ou de vidéos à la demande et
bien cette entreprise prend ses données
qu'elle stockent pour les mettre à
disposition des consommateurs finaux et
pour ce faire elle utilise un réseau et
donc en fonction de la quantité de
données transférée et de la distance que
cette donnée doit parcourir c'est ce que
nous facturons clients pour
l'utilisation du réseau
ce faisant nous réduisons aussi nos
coûts d'années en année et pour vous
donner un ordre d'idée nous avons réduit
de plus de 50% entre 2018 et 2022 les
frais d'utilisation de cette de ces
transfert de données
cette mesure d'encadrement des frais au
titre de transfert nous semble devoir
être mis en cohérence avec l'article 25
du règlement des données actuellement en
discussion à Bruxelles entre les
institutions européennes pour une raison
pour plusieurs raisons mais une en
particulier
il y aura probablement une incertitude
juridique quant à l'application de cette
mesure puisque si le projet de loi que
nous discutons aujourd'hui
s'applique dans quelques mois on
supprimant ses frais au titre du
transfert quelques mois après le
Règlement sur les données
permettra une suppression progressive de
zephrets pendant trois ans et donc ça
mettra le l'utilisateur en utilisation
délicate ou il n'aura pas le droit
d'utiliser enfin le fournisseur il
n'aura pas le droit d'utiliser les frais
de transfert puis il aura le droit à
pile n'aura plus loin donc il y aura
probablement une mise en cohérence à
faire sur ce sujet parce que sinon comme
le relève l'autorité ça pourra entraîner
des problèmes d'attractivité pour les
fournisseurs ma dernière remarque c'est
sur la portabilité des actifs numériques
et l'approche proposée aux articles 8 et
9 qui ne nous semble pas refléter la
variété et la complexité des services
d'informatique en nuage et l'utilisation
qui en est faite par nos clients cette
utilisation cette variété qui est étant
vectrice d'innovation pour toutes les
entreprises
les services d'informatique en nuages ne
sont pas comparables à des services
téléphoniques
peut-être peuvent être mis dans la
catégorie des services informatiques en
nuages la gestion d'une boîte mail comme
laposte.net des services de traitement
de photos une base de données de gestion
de contrat commerciaux ou les services
proposés par la société française Hugues
face en matière d'intelligence
artificielle tous ces services sont des
services informatiques en nuage et donc
il est important de faire attention à
une volonté d'harmonisation complète de
tous ces services qui comme je disais
peuvent apporter un certain nombre de
questions complexes de manière générale
ce que l'on constate avec nos clients
ceci utilise des briques technologiques
pour développer leurs propres
applications et leurs propres services
et donc il détermine les codes les
formats
et les briques technologiques qu'il
utilisent et lorsqu'il s'agit pour eux
pour des questions peut-être
d'innovation de changer de
[Musique]
d'harmonisation des services en tant que
tel
bien je vais devoir peut-être passer la
parole j'en avais terminé je vous
remercie
c'est les données et la vie enfin
caractère stratégique et privé de nos
données et les lois extraterritales
auxquelles vous êtes soumis entreprises
extra-hopaine américaine
sur Rocket de la NSA avec la loi FISA
vous êtes soumis de transmettre les
données des Européens oui ou non
à mon sens non le régime s'applique mais
ensuite il y en a la possibilité de
contester en justice et toute entreprise
qui opère dans un pays en dehors de
l'Union Européenne ou même dans un autre
pays en douleur que la France est soumis
à des réglementations différentes après
c'est la manière dont ces
réglementations s'appliquent le
périmètre aussi de ces réglementations
Google
merci pour votre question et la
présidente donc nous contestons aussi un
certain nombre de requêtes par le
gouvernement américain on a un train un
rapport de transparence en bon français
pardon voilà qui qui est statistiquement
plus précis avec le nombre de requêtes
par type partiologie de service il se
trouve que au bout du compte
une fois que nous nous sommes amenés à
avoir été par le juge obligé à soumettre
ou à donner ses données oui nous sommes
contraints par la loi parce que nous
sommes un acteur local à le faire et
nous respectons législations locales
partout où nous opérons
je crois que l'absence des accords de
transfert de données des Européens vers
les États-Unis vous êtes contraint de
donner les données
bon
Monsieur Hervé
merci madame la Présidente je serai là
de ne pas être content avec les
questions et échanges qu'on a pu avoir
avec un certain nombre d'entre vous mais
comme tout le monde n'était pas cette
édition très spécifique que nous avons
tout à l'heure sur les articles qui
m'incombent j'aimerais avoir votre
approche plus précise évidemment sur ces
premiers articles du texte je pense
notamment des articles premiers à 5
qui qui nous interroge et qui vont nous
permettre aussi de vous entendre sur ces
sujets afin de pouvoir au mieux adapter
le texte le cas échéant d'abord quels
sont vos relations avec les autorités
françaises les autorités
administratives indépendantes la CNIL
LARCOM larcep le pérenne c'est pas
exclusif mais comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui quels sont quelles sont les
tas de vos relations qui sont aussi
éventuellement l'état de vos difficultés
avec l'une ou l'autre de ces
institutions autorités là
commissaire en chef de commissaires
divinators en charge de pharoz nous a
indiqué travaillé en Partena avec les
opérateurs qui de même traitent des
signalements relatifs à des contenus
illicites où on a sur eux-mêmes la
détection quelles actions menez-vous de
votre côté et comment communiquez-vous
avec les autorités nationales y compris
les juridictions
comment analysez-vous les nouvelles
règles créées par le DSA
celle qui crée de nouveaux types
d'injonctions et comme celle qui
institue pardon un exposé des motifs en
cas de contenu ici ou une notification
de soupçon de réaction pénale ou encore
celle qui renforce vos obligations en
matière de transparence d'audits et
d'évaluation des risques le DSA va vous
impose de mettre en place des mesures
spécifiques pour protéger les mineurs
qu'avez-vous prévu en la matière
pensez-vous qu'il soit possible
voire opportun de développer des
dispositifs d'identité numérique allant
au-delà du simple contrôle de la
majorité quand il s'agit de contrôler
l'accès au site pornographique
ça c'était les questions générales sur
les questions des pour les différents
articles
le référentiel de vérification de
majorité mis en place à l'article
premier du projet de loi semble
concerner uniquement les éditeurs de
services de communication publique en
ligne permettant l'accès à un contenu
pornographique ne serait-il pas
également utile en dehors de ce secteur
spécifique comment vérifier vous
aujourd'hui la majorité de vos
utilisateurs et dans quel cas
procédez-vous à ce type de contrôle
les services que vous fournissez peuvent
conduire au visionnage d'image
pornographiques par des mineurs que
mettez-vous en place pour l'éviter pour
limiter
notamment dans le contrôle de vos
publicités
article 3 que pensez-vous du cadre
français de luttre contre les contenus
terroristes et pédo pornographiques
pédocrinel
quel est votre analyse sur la nouvelle
sanction pénale créée à l'article 3 en
cas de défaut du retrait par un
hébergeur d'un contenu
pédopornographique dans un délai de 24
heures
comment analyser vous l'extension des
pouvoirs de l'arcom dans la lutte contre
la diffusion des contenus produits par
les médias visés par les sanctions
européennes concrètement quelles mesures
avez-vous mise en place depuis 2022 pour
éviter la diffusion des programmes
produits par recherche today et par
Sputnik dernière question sur l'article
5 qui crée une peine complémentaire dite
de bannissement on l'évoquait tout à
l'heure dans l'audition nous avons eu
avec un certain nombre d'entre vous
elle fixe pour les plateformes deux
obligations une obligation assorties
d'une sanction pour le blocage du compte
qui a servi à commettre l'infraction et
une obligation de moyens sans
accentuction associés pour le blocage
des autres comptes de la personne qu'on
donnait avez-vous les moyens techniques
de faire respecter une telle obligation
qui est le meilleur je le rappelle en
pratique comment faites-vous lorsqu'une
c'est lorsqu'une personne est bannie de
votre service pour ne pas avoir respecté
les conditions générales d'utilisation
pour éviter qu'elle n'y reviennent en
dissimulant son identité je vous
remercie
on va les reprendre alors
alors on va essayer de prendre par
paquet de bloc
tout d'abord les relations avec les
autorités les régulateurs et les
autorités dans les régulateurs si je
comprends bien votre question dans tout
ça
nous on n'a pas attendu en fait ni la
loi fake news ni la loi
principe républicain pour engager avec
notamment l'arcom on avait déjà lancé il
y a de sa 5 ans la mission de Facebook
pour commencer à expliquer justement
régulateur comment en travailler qui a
donné le rapport d'outrelle qui est sur
lequel s'est appuyer notamment aussi le
DSA donc c'est une relation qu'on a déjà
entretenu avant même que les
réglementations arrivent auprès de ces
régulateurs car comme le disait Benoît
tout à l'heure pour nous c'était
extrêmement important et utile d'avoir
aussi un régulateur à qui on pouvait
parler et qui pouvait aussi nous aider
parfois à prendre voilà des décisions ou
au moins échanger sur les décisions
je vais prendre donc ça c'est des
relations qui sont plutôt bien mises en
place depuis plusieurs années pour ce
qui est des autorités on a une personne
qui est dédiée en France pour travailler
avec l'OCLCTIC donc farose aussi qui est
derrière c'est ce que je vous indiquais
initialement c'est à peu près 25000
réquisitions par an qui sont traitées
avec un taux de conformité approchant
90% je crois que c'est 87
la dernière fois que on avait mis le
rapport toutes les données sont
publiques sur notre apport de
transparence
la difficulté qu'on a c'est que comme le
disait aussi mon voisin de droite on a
très peu de visibilité sur combien de
ces réquisitions sont judiciarisées et
on voit très bien que dans le temps en
tout cas de la justice et des autorités
il se passe quelque chose d'où notre
proposition d'avoir cette intermédiaire
avec ses agents insermenés pardon pour
pouvoir notamment leur donner peut-être
un pouvoir qui pourrait être efficace et
nous aider en tout cas dans dans les
dispositifs qui sont mis en place parce
qu'on pourra vous retirer énormément des
millions des milliards de contenus à un
moment donné il faut aussi un pouvoir
étatique qui joue son rôle et
aujourd'hui les 57 cas pour harcèlement
on voit que ça ne suit pas toujours au
niveau au niveau judiciaire donc c'est
comment on peut trouver un entre deux
justement pour faciliter et désengorger
aussi la justice mais répondre à cette
attente des utilisateurs aussi et
comment on peut les accompagner
sur le pérenne je voulais indiquer on a
aussi eu des relations avec eux
aujourd'hui ce que je comprends en tout
cas de leur mode de fonctionnement si tu
doivent être mandatés par un régulateur
que ce soit à la recette que ce soit la
CNIL que ce soit l'arcom pour pouvoir en
tout cas
initier des études et capter des données
ce qui n'est pas du tout le projet tel
qu'il est prévu en tout cas dans
l'article 16 et c'est ce qui nous
interroge sur ces dispositifs étant
donné qu'ils sont assimilés non pas à
une institution gouv mental mais à des
chercheurs ce qui questionnent en tout
cas sur la nature des données des moyens
en tout cas qui seront mis en place et
pourquoi en tout cas ce dispositif est
mis comme ça en l'espèce aujourd'hui et
pourquoi il a pas été notifié notamment
aussi à la commission étant donné qu'il
touche aux articles 40 et 34 du DSA
la partie
alors après il y avait sur les niveaux
de type d'injonctions
nous ce qu'on a noté alors ça fait
référence plus à l'article 5 je pense
auquel vous faites référence c'est
ce qui nous pose un problème sur la
partie sur la partie de cet article
c'est pas tant le cyber-harcèlement tout
ce qui est lutte enfin on y souscrira
c'est même pas un sujet pour nous ça
fait des années qu'on le fait on le fera
toujours en revanche ce qui nous
interroge c'est sur les suspicions
justement pénales où il faudrait qu'on
retire des comptes à venir des personnes
condamnées c'est ce que j'indiquais en
préambule c'est un comment en fait on
identifie ces personnes ça supposerait
qu'on ait un fichier qui nous soit donné
les deux sensibles c'est discuter avec
la CNIL pourquoi passer un premier sujet
et deuxièmement
en fait au regard de la LCEN et du DSA
vous avez un principe de spécialité ou
en fait on doit nous notifier une URL
enfin des inscriptions très spécifiques
qui sont définies dans le DSA ça ne peut
pas être uniquement sur la base d'un nom
et prénom étant donné qu'on voit bien
les difficultés que ça peut poser sur
des homonymes et autres donc ça c'est un
vrai problématique opérationnelle qu'on
peut rencontrer et en plus c'est pas du
tout aligné pour le coup avec la manière
dont s'inscrit au DSA je me permets
juste de faire un petit retour en
arrière sur l'article 1 et 2 ou pour
nous ça serait extrêmement important de
préciser qu'il s'agit des éditeurs parce
qu'il y a une confusion dans la
terminologie utilisée ou à un moment
donné c'est éditeur à un moment donné
ces services de communication en ligne
donc on parle pas de la même chose pour
nous saviser effectivement les éditeurs
qui ont un rôle très spécifique en
l'espèce mais pas en tout cas la partie
hébergeur telle qu'on l'entend le côté
plateforme donc faudrait certainement
requalifier ça et j'avais noté également
une disposition qui nous inquiétait sur
les contenus pédophoronographiques qui
ne sont pas très clairs où il faudrait
qu'on notifie les contenus qui nous ont
été signalés et donc mettre à risque des
gens qui nous ont signalés des contenus
en les notifiant au potentiel pédocrinel
ce qui vous comprenez bien peut poser un
vrai problème aussi de sécurité tout
simplement pour les utilisateurs qui
signalent ce type de contenu donc c'est
la manière dont elle est formulée c'est
on doit notifier toute demande qui nous
a été fait aux personnes en tout cas qui
auraient été auteur de ces de ces
contenus donc voilà brièvement pour
cette partie là j'essaye de reprendre le
fil de ce que vous m'avez dit sur le
reste je crois qu'après il y avait une
grosse partie Spoutnik si je peux me
permettre
dans la manière dont c'est rédigé alors
nous on a pris les décisions telles
qu'elles nous ont été notifié et au
niveau européen et par la recom c'était
des mesures qu'on avait déjà identifié
parce qu'il y avait des violations de
contenu et au moment des discussions du
DSA on avait déjà indiqué que c'était un
problème en tout cas de labellisation
aussi de ce type de contenu et qu'il
fallait avoir un vrai sourcing donc vous
avez en fait quand vous allez sur la
plateforme Facebook ou Instagram un
petit ou vous voyez la source apparaître
ici c'est une un média qui est tenu par
un état c'est je crois cntr par exemple
pour un régime chinois vous avez que
c'est un média qui est détenu en tout
cas par par l'État chinois donc nous on
a mis en place toute cette stabilisation
quand on a bien évidemment les
informations ce qui est plutôt rassurant
c'est que ça s'appuie sur l'article 215
du traité au niveau européen donc ça
sera cadré de ce qu'on en comprend donc
à partir du moment où il y a un cadrage
et une définition précise sur de qui on
parle et comment on en parle et comment
on peut aussi les identifier
ça reste ça reste clair voilà c'était
c'était le point et je vais laisser
Antoine sur la partie identité numérique
si tu veux ajouter des éléments
me répéter effectivement la question des
jeunes publiques elle se pose de
différentes manières donc il y a la
question déjà de contenu ou d'une
expérience adaptée à ces personnes sur
Instagram par exemple quand vous êtes un
mineur certaines fonctionnalités sont
activées par défaut certains types de
contenus je parle pas que la
pornographie qui est évidemment interdit
sur ces plateformes vous sont
éventuellement présentés on a aussi un
dispositif qui fait que lorsque vous
voulez vous avez 16 ans que vous
voudriez dire que j'ai plus de 18 ans
nous avons mis un filtre avec la société
Yeti d'une analyse morphologique de
votre visage qui permet donc de créer
une barrière assez efficace puisque dans
plus de 95% des cas maintenant on a
remarqué que
si le jeune voulait mentir ben il ne
passe pas le test de yoti donc ça c'est
plutôt nouveau ça nous emmène vers un un
chemin où on progresse en matière de
contrôle de l'âge au niveau des 18 ans
il n'en demeure par mois qui demeure des
complexité sur sur l'âge
à des âges inférieurs donc on a déjà
parlé ici les 13-4 ans et je pense qu'il
faut il faut accepter l'idée que c'est
compliqué
que les jeunes aussi utilisent les
réseaux sociaux dans le cadre de droit
fondamentaux qui sont les leurs qui leur
sont reconnus liberté d'associations
liberté d'expression
aussi ça sert aussi de d'entraide dans
bien des cas donc il faut trouver le le
bon équilibre reconnaître les mérites où
ils sont et essayer aussi voilà de
juguler ces difficultés mais le DSA nous
demande de faire des analyses d'impact
particulières pour les jeunes donc elles
sont fait évidemment elle nous demande
des choses en matière de publicité donc
ça sera mis en place donc voilà donc
tout ça c'est c'est en cours mais je
réitère je pense que sur les questions
de l'âge il faut qu'on se parle le plus
et tous
un dernier élément sur les 24 heures par
rapport au contenu retrait des contenus
pédopornographiques ça c'est un
dispositif qui a été mis en place enfin
je pense le but étant de faire quelque
chose de similaire aux règlements Tissot
qui a été voté il y a pas si longtemps
ça suppose une coordination au niveau
européen parce que les contenus
pédopornographiques on a déjà en tout
cas par exemple des on tag en tout cas
les contenus et on les partage pour
justement qu'elles ne reviennent pas sur
on les partage aux autres plateformes et
aux autorités pour qu'elles ne
reviennent pas sur nos plateformes mais
ça nécessite une coordination pas eu au
niveau européen à minima voir au niveau
global avec notamment nekmek avec qui on
travaille tous pour pouvoir justement
avoir cette rapidité et cette efficacité
donc les 24 heures me paraissent
compliqué aujourd'hui sans se dispositif
là en place alors même que justement
Tisséo l'avait prévu et il y avait une
coopération entre autorité qui était
aussi initialement intégrée dans ce type
de dispositif qu'on ne retrouve pas dans
la proposition du texte français
monsieur tabaca oui alors pour essayer
effectivement essayer de synthétiser de
nombreuses choses mais sur la question
des régulateurs c'est une très bonne
question parce qu'effectivement
comme je disais on peut en introduction
pendant longtemps le régulateur naturel
internet c'était le juge donc qui est
arrivé très tardivement et effectivement
au fur et à mesure on a vu les divers
régulateurs et autorités administratives
administration comme le pérenne
s'intéresser et obtenir des compétences
complémentaires
j'allais dire de notre point de vue il
faut les poser même question
effectivement aux intéressés mais
il y a eu au tout début j'allais au tout
début sans doute je suis rentré chez
gollye à 11 ans donc disons il est 11
ans il y avait une vraie difficulté à
rentrer dans une logique de régulation
qui était vraiment orthogonale par
rapport à ce qui était à l'époque
j'allais dire le le numérique
aujourd'hui on a véritablement construit
des canaux de communication des
rencontres régulières des discussions
même sur le plan technique avec les
divers régulateurs que ça soit avec la
avec la CNIL avec l'arcom des
discussions effectivement aussi avec le
pérenne un des points par rapport à
votre question monsieur le rapporteur
sur qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait faire de
mieux ce qui est intéressant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on se rend compte que
énormément de questions sont à la
croisée des régulateurs et donc
effectivement chaque question vont être
prises par un prise le prise de la
concurrence le prime de la protection
des données le prise de la régulation
des contenus la liberté expression mais
à un moment sans doute que il faut
trouver une manière de structurer cet
échange de régulateur et notamment pour
une entreprise lorsqu'on a des questions
un peu plus complexes de pouvoir avoir
une réponse qui tienne compte de
l'ensemble des équilibres à trouver
entre les différentes droits et libertés
sur le DSA effectivement nos équipes
travaillent totalement sur la
préparation de sa mise en oeuvre c'est
parti puisque effectivement les
différentes plateformes ont été
désignées donc maintenant pour nous ça a
pas été une surprise puisque ça
correspondait exactement au service
qu'on avait anticipé de rentrer dans le
périmètre du DSA on travaille dessus
pour s'assurer
dès la mise en oeuvre des différents
dispositifs c'est-à-dire de cet été que
l'ensemble des choses soient mises en
oeuvre notamment par exemple l'avait
mentionné à chaque fois qu'il y a un
retrait de contenu de pour informer la
personne des raisons pour lesquelles il
y a eu ce retrait de contenu là de lui
offrir des capacités d'appel etc etc
donc on est on est complètement
là-dessus si je reviens sur sur les
différents articles de la loi peut-être
si je reprends en fait dans l'ordre
finalement notamment la question autour
de l'article 1 et l'article 2 sur
effectivement le blocage des sites ou du
moins la vérification de l'âge par les
sites les sites pornographiques un des
éléments
aussi qui est intéressant c'est à dire
que par exemple dans dans le dispositif
de l'article 1 il y a une référence à la
mise en place de système de vérification
d'âge sans doute serait-il opportun et
notamment si on essaie de se projeter
sur que peut-être les dispositifs demain
d'ajouter la capacité que ces
dispositifs reposent sur les opérateurs
de la communication comme ce qui existe
dans certains dans certains pays
c'est-à-dire que le contrôle de l'âge
n'est plus fait au niveau du service il
est fait au niveau de l'opérateur vous
essayez de vous connecter à un site
pornographique l'opérateur en fait va
vous communiquer un code d'accès et
c'est Lui qui connaît son tituels de
compte qui sera en mesure de donner
l'accès ou pas donc sans doute une
réflexion à voir si on veut se mécanisme
là en France mais je pense qu'il faut
pas se fermer la porte et peut-être
l'anticiper on ouvrant la capacité
d'expertiser les différentes solutions
une question que je vous pose c'est pas
du tout une suggestion l'article 227 24
on y fait référence article dont on y
fait pas référence à l'article 1 pour la
santé mais surtout l'article 227 24 ne
se limite pas au contenu pornographique
sans doute la question pour vous
législateur c'est de dire comment on
traite tous les contenus non
pornographiques du 227 24 vous avez
notamment
l'interdiction d'accéder aux mineurs à
des contenus qui les mettent en danger
qui sont pas des contenus
pornographiques des jeux dangereux des
choses comme ça pour les mineurs ils
doivent être aussi un blocage d'accès
ils sont pas dans le périmètre de la loi
deuxième élément l'article 2 vous on
revisite effectivement la mécanique qui
existe qui était quasiment finalisée
malgré tous les recours qu'on a pu voir
de certains sites la question c'est de
se dire on va sans doute réouvrir un
champ pendant deux ans trois ans de
débat judiciaire de QPC de recours
européen etc il y a-t-il un moyen de
stabiliser le texte d'une manière ou
d'une autre on apportera des
améliorations peut-être s'inspirant de
ce qui existe en matière de lutte contre
le piratage vous avez le juge qui donne
un premier tempo et la capacité pour le
régulateur de s'appuyer sur ce tempo
donné pour le juge pour être beaucoup
plus large en termes de mesure de
blocage sur la question la lutte qu'on
doit perdre pédopornographie c'est un
vrai vrai problème chaque trimestre on
retire ou en bloc environ quasiment 7
millions de contenus et le
pornographiques on notifié aux autorités
américaines qui ont ensuite les
distribues dans les différents pays et à
la fin l'office centrale 1,1 millions de
personnes dont le monde la France et
selon les années le deuxième troisième
pays qui héberge des contenus pédaux
pornographiques on a un problème et on a
un problème aussi en France donc la
réponse est oui il faut que cette mesure
se mette en œuvre sans doute que si vous
voulez être encore plus efficace prévoir
un rapport de transparence où sont
stockés les contenus que les autorités
ont demandé leur suppression parce que
si on a un problème en France je pense
qu'il est important le savoir article 4
sur les mesures prises notamment
vis-à-vis des contenus
j'allais de type russe Châteaudun et
peut-être demain pour d'autres pour
d'autres régimes ou autres pour donner
un peu des ordres d'idées sur la base de
la gestion de la Commission européenne
côté YouTube on a bloqué 800 chaînes et
plus de 4 millions de vidéos
c'est à dire que c'est pas uniquement
riche chatouday et Sputnik c'est
beaucoup plus et c'est beaucoup plus
volumétrique un des points d'attention
mais qui sera un point d'attention aussi
pour le régulateur alors un
effectivement c'est important d'avoir
cette mécanique là deux il faut savoir
que et on l'a vu notamment avec ils sont
revenus par une autre plateforme qui
s'appelle l'Odyssée on l'a fait des
référencer par le moteur de recherche ça
a été suite à notification du ministre
du numérique à l'époque mais c'est vrai
que donner des pouvoirs au régulateurs
de pouvoir plus facilement rentrer dans
cette dans ce système là c'est plutôt
positif un des points à garder en tête
pour vous pour vos réflexions sachez
qu'aujourd'hui la désinformation des
pratiques d'influence étrangères
prennent de plus en plus l'apparence et
la qualification juridique de médias
c'est à dire que aujourd'hui ce sont des
médias
du moins dans leur pays qui vont venir
et qui vont diffuser la désinformation
donc le fait que on met l'arcom comme
régulateur c'est une bonne chose parce
que effectivement c'est le régulateur
des médias
si on vient sur l'article 5 j'en ai dit
deux mots effectivement en introduction
faut imaginer que si on prend l'exemple
vous avez parlé avec avec les équipes
précédemment mais comme je disais
aujourd'hui sont les chiffres de la
Chancellerie c'est 54 personnes qui sont
condamnées chaque année pour l'effet de
cyber-harcèlement et donc plusieurs
années avant je voulais vous mettre en
parallèle en France c'est à peu près
entre 150 et 160 000 contenus qu'on
supprime de YouTube
c'est à dire on a 54 d'un côté 160 000
de l'autre la question qu'est-ce qu'on
fait vis-à-vis de toutes ces personnes
là aujourd'hui on a mécanisé en France
qui permet d'envoyer un email
d'avertissement une personne qui a
téléchargé ou piraté un film on n'est
pas capable d'envoyer un email même
d'avertissement à une personne qui tient
les propos antisémites qui tient du
harcèlement nous quitter des propos
haineux en ligne alors que la mécanique
existe le régulateur existe et les
outils juridiques existent et je pense
que c'est ça la vraie réflexion en
termes d'efficacité du dispositif oui on
a la possibilité effectivement de
bloquer des comptes c'est compliqué
techniquement si on veut s'assurer
au-delà d'une obligation de moyens d'un
vrai blocage de la réouverture d'un
compte ça va nécessiter sans doute de
récupérer beaucoup plus d'informations
et ça soulagera des questions en termes
de protection des données et donc c'est
juste une discussion qu'il faudra sans
t'avoir avec la CNIL de savoir où est-ce
qu'on met les moyens la collègue des
données et les interconnexions mais on
fera ça pour 54 personnes qui sont
condamnées et à condition encore que le
juge pour chacune d'entre elles prononce
la peine complémentaire l'interdiction
de réseaux sociaux donc sans doute on
fera ça pour 25 personnes chaque année
donc la question c'est de se dire si on
veut être efficace ça peut être utile et
potentiellement c'est une mesure qu'on
peut imaginer la question c'est où
est-ce qu'on peut mettre d'autres
mesures beaucoup plus efficaces
impactantes et je m'arrêterai là
peut-être mon dernier mot effectivement
vous les avez abordé la question la
protection de la jeunesse et de la
vérification d'âge sans rentrer dans des
détails techniques sur l'ensemble de nos
plateformes on a des systèmes qui vont
permettre à un moment
d'identifier ce que j'appellerai une
sorte d'incertitude une incohérence une
personne qui va regarder énormément de
contenu pour enfants sur sur Youtube une
personne qui va télécharger des
applications jeunesse sur Google Play
mais qu'il en ont système n'est pas
présenté comme une personne mineure ça
va créer une incohérence derrière un
mécanisme à se mettre en place une
vérification va intervenir qui pourra se
faire soit par la carte bancaire soit
pour la fourniture d'une pièce
d'identité et ça permettra en cas de
doute de laisser de pousser la personne
dans un univers jeunesse et si le doute
est levé de laisser aller dans un
univers tout public voilà donc je pense
qu'il y a pas mal de réflexion à avoir
effectivement une des questions qu'on
peut se poser en terme aussi de
d'équivalence on parlait aujourd'hui de
blocage par l'arcome de sites qui ne
propose pas la vérification d'âge et on
parlait de la ville soulever à juste
titre que ça concernait les sites
pornographiques si demain et notamment
avec un certain nombre de dispositifs
récents le bleu la déferication d'âge
doit être sur d'autres types
d'applications la question est de se
dire est-ce que le rôle de l'arkum doit
pas être tendu à tous les types de
vérification d'âge et notamment de
s'assurer que ce que ce respect
intervient bien et le dernier élément et
c'est mon dernier mot aujourd'hui on se
rend compte que et notamment ça reboule
qu'avec mon premier point sur les
régulateurs
on est on commence à avoir émerger les
mêmes logiques de régulation et
notamment en matière de contrôle des
contenus sur Internet avec la capacité
pour une autorité administrative de
retirer du contenu pour différentes
raisons et derrière une autorité
référente ma recommandation notre
recommandation ça serait sans doute de
concentrer ces personnalités qualifiées
comme son souvent qualifiées par la loi
au sein du même autorité c'est à dire
que par exemple dans certains cas on va
le confier à l'acnil dans d'autres cas
on va le mettre à l'arc comme peut-être
demain on ira chercher d'autres
autorités on a capitalisé sur une
personnalité qualifiée au sein de
l'arcom des services ils ont une
connaissance ils ont une culture ils ont
des process la question c'est de se dire
pourquoi ne pas spécialiser quand il
s'agit de contenu une autorité et
s'assurer que on fait converger et on
fait converger les moyens vers cette
autorité voilà je m'arrêterai là merci
monsieur le rapport est-ce que amazon a
quelques mots en quelques mots parce que
beaucoup de choses ont été dites
en effet vous avez raison et puis je
voudrais pas répéter ce qui a été dit je
mettrai l'accent sur
deux points en ce qui concerne la
protection de l'enfance qui est
engagement très fort de d'Amazon
d'abord si vous évoquez cette question
monsieur le rapporteur les questions de
vérification d'âge devait être étendu à
d'autres domaines
dans ce cas là il y a une procédure qui
est mise en place avec effectivement le
rôle de l'arcom et de la CNIL qui
pourrait donner lieu qui est une
procédure intéressante parce qu'elle
procède justement une consultation de
standards techniques et d'un référentiel
technique
moi les deux points sur lesquels je
voulais peut-être attirer l'attention
c'est d'abord le la nécessité de de
travailler avec des associations avec
les associations qui sont engagées sur
ces questions nous nous le faisons avec
des associations
[Musique]
le lieu pour expérimenter dont nous
sommes également un membre fondateur qui
qui est une initiative pilotée par
l'ambassadeur Verdier que que vous
connaissez donc il est important de
trouver les moyens d'une harmonisation
d'une harmonisation des standards et je
crois que la France avec ses initiatives
et peut-être d'autres à un rôle
effectivement tout à fait moteur dans
ces domaines dans auquel on s'associe en
tant qu'entreprise dans ces deux cas qui
sont les deux plus pertinents voilà ce
que je voulais dire en quelques mots
sur oui on a des employeur assez chargé
beaucoup d'obligations tant que sénateur
va poser ces questions sur la partie
plutôt informatique en nuage c'est ça
parce que
en fait quatre sujets
à aborder donc en m'excusant par avance
sa vision de mon départ précipité mais
j'écouterai bien sûr avec attention vos
réponses par le biais de du numérique
donc d'abord première premier sujet
c'est le filtre anti arnaque que vous
allez aborder très rapidement donc ma
question ou mes questions serait de
savoir comment vos entreprises
vont contribuer au déploiement du filtre
anti arnaque
et également pour les fournisseurs
navigateurs internet de quelle façon
vous allez répondre aux demandes des
autorités administratives pour prendre
les mesures qui donc sont prévues par le
texte sur l'informatique en nuage donc
vous avez
parlé donc néanmoins je crois que
constat qu'on peut faire c'est que vos
entreprises ont aujourd'hui un poids
certain donc sur ce marché et un
sentiment se dégage c'est qu'il y a
quand même une forme de verrou du marché
donc par rapport aux entreprises
françaises donc j'ai entendu vos
réponses sur les crédits cloud avec vos
votre approche que je partage en partie
sur les entreprises
startups qui ont besoin de ces crédits
cloud néanmoins donc
quel est votre avis particulier sur le
les orientations qui sont prises et
notamment sur le fait de limiter dans le
temps ces crédits Cloud
et puis donc sur la suppression des
frais de transfert vous en avez parlé
mais peut-être rappeler les uns et les
autres quel est votre posture sur le
sujet et ce que vous avez tous donc la
position qui est de dire non on ne
facture pas de frais de transfert auquel
cas donc l'intégrer dans la loi n'aurait
aucune conséquence et donc ne poserait
problème à personne
voilà pour cette partie Cloud sur
l'intermédiation de données
donc
est-ce que vous pouvez nous donner
quelques exemples concrets de donner qui
pourraient être partagé volontairement
par des entreprises sur ces nouvelles
plateformes numériques et enfin
si vous permettez qu'on puisse aborder
l'article 15 et
les jauneshumes les jeux objets
numériques monétisable
que vous
demandant si vos entreprises en
développe et on propose et enfin si vous
pensez que
encombrantment spécifique et nécessaire
sur ces genoux voilà j'étais rapide
synthétique mais voilà les quatre sujets
sur lequel j'aimerais avoir vos réponses
par
mon côté moi je m'arrêterai uniquement
sur l'article 6 et effectivement pour
aussi sur l'article 15 sur le genou on
n'en fait pas et on est pas directement
concerné donc on a aucun commentaire
là-dessus sur article 6 effectivement
d'ores et déjà en fait on développe une
solution technique qu'on s'appelle sève
browsing qui en fait un outil mis à
disposition de tous les acteurs
aujourd'hui dans dans le monde qui
permet effectivement sur la base des
analyses qui sont menées par nos équipes
et notamment à base de l'intelligence
artificielle de détecter des suspicions
de fichiers de téléchargement de
logiciels malveillants et autres donc
aujourd'hui ça permet d'ores et déjà
d'afficher dans votre navigateur le ces
informations là sachant que cette cet
outil qui est une API partagée aussi
bien dans une navigateur de type Safari
Firefox Google Chrome mais aussi qu'on
va retrouver dans les navigateurs
internes de certains applications qui
utilisent également ces outils là donc
ça voilà on est déjà en train de
travailler là dessus et on est en train
de regarder pour rien vous cacher
comment on fait l'outil technique tel
qu'il existe peut s'articuler
effectivement par rapport au cadre
juridique français en sachant qu'il faut
savoir que un blocage au travers de cet
outil là sera par nature mondiale
c'est-à-dire que la mesure prise par la
France de dire je suspecte ce contenu là
d'être une arnaque aura un effet mondial
c'est-à-dire qu'il sera bloqué
effectivement en France il sera bloqué
en Europe il sera bloqué aux États-Unis
en Asie et donc effectivement partant
sur l'aspect là nous on a commencé
effectivement à réfléchir sur l'article
6 comme je le disais très brièvement en
introduction il sera intéressant de de
mettre en place une sorte de guichet
unique vis-à-vis de nous des autorités
puisqu'on a compris que potentiellement
6 à 7 autorité seront en mesure de
signaler des contenus il faut qu'il y
ait un guichet unique centralise ces
contenus là en termes de facilité de la
même manière sans doute qu'il faudrait
avoir de l'autre côté ce que je disais
aussi une personnalité qualifiée qui
reçoit ces signalements et
je connais pas s'appuyer quand je disais
auparavant sur l'arcom ils ont les
connaissances ils ont les compétences
plutôt que de vouloir une des idées de
confier cette mission peut-être à la
CNIL pourquoi pas mais a priori la
clinique pourrait être à la fois
autorité notifiante et personnalité
qualifiée donc sans doute peut-être
séparer les deux aspects avoir un
mécanisme de dialogue entre nous les
autorités pour éviter ce qui s'est passé
récemment avec le blocage de télégram
pour une mauvaise configuration de des
éléments par par les opérateurs comme je
disais sur la partie sanction
effectivement sans doute aligner le
les formulations avec les concepts de
j'essaie de trouver la bonne traduction
française je sais pas si c'est failles
systémique ou en tout cas violation
systémique des obligations pour
s'assurer qu'on soit à peu près aligné
sur la logique des sa
puisqu'effectivement pour un cas on peut
avoir un problème donc c'est plutôt la
mauvaise volonté de mise en oeuvre la
loi qui devrait être sanctionner et
dernier point je pense que ce serait
intéressant notamment là dessus
puisqu'on est pour la première fois sur
quelque chose ou l'état en fait va
filtrer en quelque sorte massivement du
contenu sans doute avoir beaucoup plus
de transparence peut-être un rapport
annuel ça sera intéressant ou une
opération de communication qu'on
demanderait au gouvernement de faire
pour informer les gens et le dernier
point je l'ai mentionné très rapidement
c'est dire effectivement aujourd'hui
l'obligation va peser principalement sur
sur des navigateurs et autres la
question c'est de se dire mais si on
veut vraiment mettre en place cette
mesure est-ce qu'elle devrait pas aussi
c'est pas forcément exclusif reposer sur
les opérateurs puisqu'effectivement
c'est là la mesure la plus efficace quoi
qu'il arrive voilà donc je m'arrêterai
là je passe peut-être la parole à
Frédéric soit partie cloud merci
beaucoup
sur la partie des crédits
alors si on prend spécifiquement le cas
des startups et je vais vous donner
quelques chiffres je pense que ça va
être aussi intéressant ces crédits sont
déjà limités dans le temps à deux ans
voilà on n'est pas favorable à une
période plus courte alors on a entendu
dans d'autres auditions que certains
parlaient d'un an voilà on participera
avec ces discussions avec joie une
nouvelle fois mais pour vous donner
peut-être quelques chiffres sur l'année
2021 en France Google cloud a soutenu au
travers de ces crédits 4414 startups et
en moyenne c'est start-up on consommait
pour 1300 euros de ces crédits donc
c'est aussi pour peut-être lutter contre
des fantasmes sur des centaines de
milliers ou dizaines de milliers d'euros
qui sont mis à disposition voilà on est
sur des sommes quand on est sur 1300 en
moyenne euro de crédit par startup je
pense que un certain nombre d'autres
acteurs du marché sont capables d'offrir
le même type de conditions
donc
hors startup ça a été déjà dit lors de
cette audition mais il est vrai que ça
aide le tissu économique français et les
entreprises françaises à adopter des
technologies numériques et à adopter les
technologies d'information en nuage sur
la partie des des coups de transfert
vraiment j'y reviens mais on a eu du mal
à on a du mal à comprendre le texte on a
l'impression vraiment que il ne parle il
prend
l'exact opposé de des discussions qui au
niveau européen notamment si je
caricature entre les coups de sortie
lorsqu'on quitte un fournisseur pour
aller chez un autre mais on met fin à sa
relation contractuelle et les coûts de
transfert quand ces données vont aller
travailler ailleurs chez un autre
fournisseur dans des cas de multiplables
pour ensuite revenir chez le chez le
fournisseur originel et là où il y a des
coups de réseau des coûts de transport
et qui qui il faut bien répercuter aux
clients final
sur donc repréciser nous aussi ça a été
dit dans une audition précédente avec
des acteurs européens mais nous ne
faisons pas de pénalité c'est
strictement et simplement le coût
d'utilisation des réseaux lors du
transport de ces données voilà mais nous
sommes prêts à continuer à discuter
vraiment dans le détail de ces
différents coups de transfert sur la
partie alors j'oublie toujours le terme
sur l'intermédiation de données
pardonnez-moi là on participe nous
Google cloud on est un des membres de de
cette initiative du secteur privé
d'industrie européenne qui s'appelle
Gaya x donc vous avez je le sais déjà
entendu parler et qui réunit des acteurs
industriels par n'ont pas branche on
dirait dans un monde de syndicats
professionnels français mais par
activité et donc aujourd'hui il y a je
pense qu'on peut les citer en exemple de
groupe de travail au sein de Gaïa x 1
qui s'intéresse plus particulièrement au
service financier aux banques et aux
assurances qui a beaucoup avancé sur ces
questions de comment partager les
données avec quel type de sécurité pour
quel type du sage et aussi avec des
fournisseurs de rang 1 de rangs 3
puisque il y a une complexité naturelle
qui vient tout de suite et on sait aussi
que le le groupe de travail qui suit les
questions autour de l'automobile au sein
de Gaïa x aussi a déjà beaucoup avancé
sur ces questions donc nous on part du
principe que l'ensemble de l'industrie
lorsqu'elle arrive à se mettre autour de
la table et à discuter pour mettre des
standards des des processus de
communication et d'interopérabilité
entre les acteurs et toujours une
excellente solution et donc on
continuera de participer activement aux
travaux
merci et pour AWS
merci madame la Présidente pour
reprendre un petit peu ce point
peut-être je commencerai sur un domaine
qui est qui relève pas a priori de
l'activité d'AWS mais peut-être sur la
question du filtre interne donc on n'est
pas producteur de contenu à l'évidence
sont plutôt nos clients qui utilisent
nos briques technologies pour construire
des sites qui le cas échéant peuvent
avoir des contenus particuliers ça fait
liens aussi avec les discussions qu'on a
eu tout à l'heure sur les contenus
pédopornographiques juste en un point et
de manière très rapide
la politique que l'on applique et en
conformité avec avec la réglementation
européenne en particulier le
sur ce sujet c'est que comme on n'a pas
le contrôle sur un contenu on peut pas
avoir une approche granulaire d'un
contenu à retirer et donc ce faisant on
a une politique d'utilisation du service
qui est assez stricte qui oblige le
client à respecter évidemment les
réglementations applicables mais
également nos termes de service qui
prohib tout type de contenu égal et à
partir du moment où ce contenu nous
serait notifié par plusieurs moyens et
bien nous ferons nous ferons en sorte de
travail avec le client effectivement
pour faire en sorte que ce tirus ce
contenu soit retiré et si c'était pas le
cas le seul moyen qui est à disposition
c'est de fermer l'accès aux comptes
quand je dis aux comptes c'est à la
plateforme en entier puisqu'encore une
fois nous n'avons pas donné accès aux
données de nos clients donc nous ne
pouvait nous ne pouvons pas faire
autrement et autre chose que de fermer
l'accès à la plateforme sur la question
des crédits je pense que tout a été déjà
dit effectivement c'est une somme est
une nécessité en tout cas c'est ce que
nous rapporte nos clients petite moyenne
entreprise mais également les
entreprises de taille plus importante
pour des besoins d'expérimentation des
services et de la technologie
la question de la durée
me semble être plus lié à la complexité
du projet en tant que tel donc
effectivement on a des programmes un peu
similaires qui ont mesurer de 1 ou 2 ans
en fonction de la de la complexité du
projet informatique et en toute état de
cause on sera ravi d'en discuter avec
les membres de cette commission pour
pour voir quel serait les données les
plus les durées les plus appropriées en
matière de frais de transfert
j'en ai déjà parlé dans mon propos mon
propos liminaire il y a une vraie
distinction à faire encore une fois
entre les pratiques délibérées qui
fissent qui visent à bloquer un
changement de prestataire d'une d'une
d'un modèle économique qui consiste à
facturer l'utilisation d'un réseau je
pense qu'il y a une distinction qui est
très importante et en toute état de
cause comme je l'ai rappelé tout cela
est aussi lié à la complexité du projet
informatique l'utilisateur le client
l'entreprise à sa part aussi de
responsabilité dans le dans le transfert
et en fonction de la manière dont il a
codé son service et développer son son
application donc
[Musique]
pour en revenir au texte il faut il faut
brabler en prêter attention au périmètre
et à la définition puisque Fred
transfert est définie de façon
suffisamment large et peu englober
l'ensemble des frais notamment que le
que le client serait amené à dépenser
avec un prestataire extérieur du fait de
la complexité que j'ai évoqué de
l'architecture de la solution qui leur
est lui-même mis en oeuvre je pense
qu'il y a quand même une approche un peu
plus distinctif à faire en cette en
cette matière sur l'intermédiation de
données enfin
c'est la question des espaces de données
qui est un sujet effectivement de fond
il n'y a pas encore en tant que tel des
espaces de données constituées il y a
neuf projets comme vous le savez au
niveau européen transport finance et
autres qui sont qui sont en cours en
cours d'élaboration et notamment dans le
domaine de la santé si je ne m'abuse
nous faisons également partie de KX
depuis sa création à la demande de nos
clients et dans ce cas nous avons
participé au développement des
standard commun standards qui ont été
pris en compte dans les niveaux de
conformité de gax et en décembre dernier
nous avons été la première entreprise
que vous qualifierez peut-être
d'American de à pouvoir se conformer
lors de d'une démonstration à l'ensemble
des critères de gax que ce soit en
matière de de portabilité de données et
de et de transfert dans l'opérateur et
un autre en fonction du code suippo qui
a été nommé tout à l'heure ou en matière
de protection des données car à cet
égard nous avons plus d'une centaine de
services qui sont conformes au code de
protection des données 6p qui a été
validé par l'ensemble des autorités de
protection européenne avec la clinique
en chef de fil
je vous remercie bien alors je vais
donner la parole à nos collègues
Florence bertrice compta et toi ne
mourra pour poser leurs questions parce
que elles ont pas si un moment attendu
qu'on est posé les nôtres donc allez-y
chers collègues merci madame la
Présidente vous avez indiqué dans vos
propos introductifs que l'enjeu de ce
texte était bien de retrouver la
confiance et la concurrence sur ces
marchés du numérique et je me satisfais
Monsieur Jérôme que vous ayez indiqué
que vous souhaitiez à marcher toujours
plus ouvert
cela dit je souhaitais vous interpeller
sur la question la publicité en ligne
même si c'est pas directement en lien
avec le texte mais c'est quand même une
question de concurrence essentielle le
ministère américain de la Justice a
apporté plein de comptes Google en
janvier pour avoir utilisé des méthodes
illégales et par ailleurs Google est
visé par une enquête de la Commission la
commissaire à la concurrence Margaret de
stagiaires westigeur a indiqué que
Google je pourrais avoir abusé de sa
position dominante en favorisant ses
propres services et donc ce qui vous est
rapproché c'est de favoriser vos propres
services de technologie d'affichage
publicitaire en ligne au détriment de
prestataires de service de technologie
publicitaire d'annonceur et d'éditeurs
et c'est en voilà un reproche que l'on
entend des entreprises donc quel est
votre appréciation de ces griefs et
avez-vous la volonté de mettre fin à ces
pratiques qu'on peut qualifier d'Antic
concurrentiel et comment et d'autre part
concernant la publicité d'une manière
plus large le DMA implique de ne plus
utiliser les données personnelles d'un
utilisateur à des fins de publicité
ciblées sans son consentement explicite
pouvez-vous nous expliquer comment c'est
mis en oeuvre et enfin sur le marché du
cloud vous avez indiqué que c'est un
marché dynamique qu'il de nombreux
nouveaux opérateurs dont le chiffre
d'affaires augmente il faut bien quand
même constater que en part de marché sur
le marché européen les opérateurs
européens ont vu leur part de marché
fondre donc on est bien quand même
encore dans une concentration du marché
avec une domination
des opérateurs extra-européens donc vous
semblez critiquer les mesures qui sont
proposées donc quelle solution
finalement nous proposez-vous pour
rendre le marché du cloud plus
contestable et si j'ai bien compris je
voudrais peut-être avoir une précision
quand vous évoquez le la possibilité de
facturer l'utilisation du réseau est-ce
que vous pensez aux frais de bande
passante et à combien
s'élèvent en moyenne c'est c'est
facturations on va dire pour une petite
entreprise une enfin en fonction de la
taille les entreprises en fonction des
données bergées
je vous remercie je vous demande de bien
noter les questions je vais passer la
parole à Madame bourra et après vous
aurez bien sûr la parole pour les
réponses merci madame la Présidente
alors concernant le
cyber-harcèlement déjà moi je pense que
si on autorisait pas les pseudonymats
qui permettent la multiplicité des
comptes ça limiterait très largement la
publication de contenu haineux et puis
sauf erreur de ma part le principe du
dessin est de faire en sorte que ce qui
est ce qui n'existe ce qui est interdit
hors ligne soit interdit en ligne et il
me semble bien que dans la vraie vie on
ne peut pas avoir plusieurs
identités dans le cadre de ce texte il
est clairement demandé aux plateformes
de supprimer les contenus illicites
qu'elle relais dès le signalement de la
victime
et parce qu'aujourd'hui quand on est
victime de cyber-harcèlement on subit la
double peine donc non seulement on est
victime de cyber-harcèlement mais en
plus on doit apporter la preuve de ce
qu'on avance et pendant ce temps la
publication la viralité fait que ça
continue à être diffuser à des milliers
de personnes donc pour mieux modérer les
réseaux vous avez évoqué pour certains
d'entre vous vous dotez de ressources
techniques mais personne n'a évoqué les
moyens humains les ressources les
ressources humaines pour mieux pour
mieux modérer en tous les cas là pour
assurer la modération
des différentes plateformes est-ce que
vous pouvez qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire sur ce point là ensuite
concernant le contrôle de l'âge je pense
que l'idée d'associer les opérateurs qui
ont tous les éléments concernant les
identités des détenteurs du compte et de
chaque membre de la famille est une idée
très intéressante pour autant je crois
que c'est vous monsieur qui avait évoqué
uti je crois pour pouvoir j'ai mal
compris le start-up britannique qui
développe des solutions de contrôle de
l'âge
l'âge est-ce que je voulais savoir si ce
contrôle de l'âge j'imagine que c'est en
morphologique est-ce que c'est corréler
à une pièce d'identité non justement ça
ça permet de de résoudre le problème qui
qui donc l'absence d'une pièce
d'identité et pour autant parce que 13
14 ans ou 15 ans on n'a pas forcément
une pièce d'identité mais et puis on il
faut aussi approcher ça de manière
globale de beaucoup de pays où il y a
pas ce type de document mais là la
morphologie donc les études qui ont été
faites autour de ça permettent
aujourd'hui de donner un âge en fonction
de votre morphologie c'est pas de la
reconnaissance faciale on ne sait pas
qui vous êtes c'est la reconnaissance
morphologique oui mais on sait pas non
plus si celui qui se met devant l'écran
et bien celui qui va utiliser je pense
qu'on veut vérifier l'âge et l'identité
ce sont deux questions qui sont
importantes mais la question de l'âge
peut être résolue par iotis si ce
problème qu'on veut résoudre la question
de l'identité est encore une autre une
autre chose puisqu'on ne vérifie pas
l'identité à l'inscription aujourd'hui
on demande pas la carte d'identité de
quelqu'un qui s'inscrit sur les réseaux
il me semble important de vérifier c'est
que celui qui va utiliser le réseau
social et bien à l'âge conforme et donc
avec cette solution là je ne vois pas
comment on peut garantir que celui qui a
qui s'est identifié au départ et bien le
détenteur de du téléphone vous voyez ce
que je veux dire oui bien sûr mais je
pense que là c'est une question aussi de
proportion des moyens et du type de
document que vous souhaitez que l'on
collecte et je pense que c'est un
équilibre qui convient que législateur
fixe mais c'est un sujet
et puis pour terminer je me ferais le
porte-parole de mon collègue
laurenceaumont qui s'excuse mais qui a
dû quitter
nos émissions et qui voulait savoir donc
là on part dans la sur le sujet du
commerce en ligne
si vous vous assurez que la législation
du pays vendeur d'un produit voilà
est-ce qu'on s'assure que dans le pays
du client quand un produit est envoyé
dans un dans un autre pays est-ce qu'on
s'assure que la législation est conforme
en clair si j'achète de la drogue si la
drogue est autorisée dans un pays est-ce
que six mois dans un pays où ça n'est
pas autorisé je l'achète dans un pays
autorisé est-ce qu'on s'assure que la
législation est respectée
bien je vous remercie merci pour ces
cette double série de questions j'espère
que vous avez bien pris en note pour
répondre à nos collègues donc on va
commencer par les questions de Madame
latrix compta alors Monsieur tabacar et
après bien entendu les uns les autres je
vais faire un
je vais répondre à toutes les questions
en même temps de mon côté bien
évidemment les sujets Cloud pour
Frédéric soit publicité je vais pas
commenter spécifiquement les cas qu'on
pouvait bien vous en douter
où est-ce qu'on en est aujourd'hui sur
le marché en fait de la publicité ce
qu'on se rend compte en fait c'est que
pendant très longtemps le marché de la
publicité était même défini comme un
duo-paul entre d'un côté Google et
Facebook
aujourd'hui ça évolue très très
fortement et on voit en fait cette
évolution qui est en train de
s'accélérer si je prends un exemple
aujourd'hui Microsoft a racheté une
structure qui s'appelle Xender c'est eux
qui par exemple gère dorénavant la
publicité sur Netflix donc Netflix qui
est rentré très fortement sur le marché
publicitaire en ligne avec toutes les
interactions qui peut y avoir avec
également les chaînes de télévision la
matière
je peux jeter mon chapeau et aussi à
Amazon qui a une croissance publicitaire
largement plus forte que la nôtre même
celle de de méta aujourd'hui en termes
de développement économique
Apple aussi est rentré sur le marché à
publicité des études estiment qui vont
faire à peu près 30 milliards de revenus
publicitaires d'ici les trois quatre
prochaines années ils sont en train et
même de développer énormément d'outils
technologiques ce qu'on appelle de la
tech autour des questions publicitaires
ils ne sont pas là aujourd'hui on peut
regretter mais Tik Tok aussi pareil sans
rentrer de manière assez forte sur le
marché publicitaire je crois que
aujourd'hui il réalise à peu près 10
milliards de revenus publicitaires
chaque année ce qui ce qui nous
négligeable donc effectivement la
dynamique publicitaire elle se développe
elle se crée
il y a énormément vous avez raison de
questions même si on regarde en fait sur
le marché des technologies publicitaires
vous avez des acteurs comme trait death
qui sont vus comme étant des entreprises
qui croient le plus
mais aussi en même temps vous avez des
bouleversements technologiques qui
impactent le marché publicitaire vous
avez prochainement ça a commencé à être
bloqué notamment par le navigateur
d'Apple Safari c'est les cookies le
marché publicitaire opposé énormément
sur sur les cookies nous on a annoncé
que le blocage progressif des cookies
sur les cimetières démarra l'année
prochaine pour laisser le temps à
l'ensemble du secteur technologique de
trouver des solutions des nouvelles
technologies et des choses qui soient
conformes en matière de protection des
données et notamment comme disait ça
s'intègre avec les questions de DML
recueil du consentement donc voilà donc
tout ça pour dire que
il y a des cas qui sont en cours je peux
pas bien évidemment les commenter mais
ce que nous on observe en tout cas c'est
une dynamique très forte en matière
publicitaire un développement d'acteurs
qui n'était pas historiquement soit
publicité qui viennent qui bouleverse
complètement les cartes aujourd'hui de
l'équipe publicitaire et normalement
d'acteurs qui viennent s'intercaler en
termes d'intermédiation dans ce secteur
publicitaire et c'est quelque chose
en tout cas auquel nous nous on constate
et vous avez raison le DMA ajoute en
plus des éléments des éléments
concernant l'utilisation des données le
recueil du consentement et on est en
train de travailler là-dessus
puisqu'effectivement on attend aussi un
certain nombre de lignes directrices de
la part de la Commission sur la manière
dont on interprète chacun des articles
et le deuxième pont également lié au des
mains c'est que aussi nous servent
publicitaires vont rentrer dans le
périmètre du DMA donc il va y avoir des
obligations complémentaires à celle qui
existe pour les autres acteurs
publicités conformément au DMA
cyber-harcèlement effectivement
aujourd'hui
parliez de pseudonymat et c'est vrai
qu'on est aujourd'hui dans une logique
très forte de pseudonymat sur Internet
vous avez tout à fait raison
la même manière disait effectivement
dans la vie de tous les jours on a pas
de différence d'identité mais
potentiellement qu'on se promène dans la
rue que les personnes prononcent des
propos des propos même illégaux on
connaît pas automatiquement leur nom ce
qui est important je pense en la matière
est-ce que c'était le point que je
faisais sur sur comment mon commentaire
sur l'article 5 c'est que les gens on le
sentiment d'impunité quand vous avez 50
personnes qui se retrouvent en justice
au bout de quatre ans ou 50 pour l'effet
de cyber-harcèlement alors qu'on sait
pertinemment que le volume de contenu
publié sur Internet et largement
supérieur il y a un sujet et vous avez
raison de l'avoir rappeler le DSA la loi
française d'abord le dessin maintenant
va imposer aux plateforme des
obligations de retrait de ces contenus
on va retirer les contenus on va dire
aux gens on la retiré ce contenu là
parce qu'au faisiez des faits de de
cyber intimidation de harcèlement sur
Youtube ça représente alors j'ai pas le
pardonnez-moi j'ai pas la granularité au
niveau au niveau national mais il faut
imaginer qu'au niveau global l'effet de
cyber-harcèlement les raisons pour
lesquelles on supprime des contenus sur
Youtube pour des faits de harcèlement et
je parle uniquement des vidéos pas des
commentaires ça représente à peu près
500 000 contenus tous les trimestres
donc c'est quelque chose qui évolue
métriquement important et donc
effectivement par rapport à cela
plusieurs éléments premier élément on a
besoin d'éléments techniques
parce qu'on a besoin de faire ce qu'on
appellerait la pêche au chalut c'est à
dire qu'on a besoin de ramener les
contenus les plus évidents et d'avoir
des outils technologiques qui bloquent
ça ensuite on a un système d'entonnoir
qui permet d'amener les contenus pour
lequel on a des interrogations vers des
équipes de modérateurs humains et
d'avoir une intervention humaine il y a
des cas très grands la technologie peut
traiter cet aspect là et effectivement
avec le des le DSA vous aurez en plus
des messages qui partiront qui
permettront de faire appel et derrière
si quelqu'un dit je conteste la mesure
de suppression que vous avez appliqué
sur mon contenu là ça revient bien
évidemment à l'équipe de modération
humaine et ça marchera et ça permettra
effectivement de fluidifier ça mais je
pense que un des aspects et vous l'avez
bien rappelé c'est de dire ce qui est
interdit dans la vie offline comme doit
être interdit en ligne et c'est pour ça
je faisais le parallèle par exemple sur
le dispositif qui existe en matière
d'amende pour le harcèlement de rue on
n'a pas le même mécanisme en ligne et
c'est ça aussi qu'il faut retravailler
de se dire on a aujourd'hui une
volumétrie qui fait que qu'est-ce qui se
passe on va supprimer du contenu à la
fin on arrivera même à supprimer des
comptes de la plateforme la personne le
lendemain ira cyberharcelé sa victime
depuis deux plateformes a basculera d'un
réseau social vers un site Internet vers
la messagerie vers d'autres mécanismes
et à la fin c'est pas parce que
effectivement la personne on vise le
réseau social initial où il y avait
cette interaction
malaisante que la personne s'arrêtera
elle continuera harceler elle passera
par d'autres biais etc etc et c'est pour
ça que ce qui est important on a mis en
place un mécanisme et on a un travail
européen qui est en train de se mettre
en place sur on supprime le contenu il
faut maintenant redescendre un niveau
qui est de dire l'auteur comment on
traite l'auteur du contenu en plus de
traiter le contenu sont deux choses deux
actions à menées en parallèle voilà et
juste la question posée sur le commerce
avec le commerce en ligne mais nous on
n'a pas activités pur et dur de commerce
en ligne mais sachez que par exemple on
a cette situation là en matière de
pharmacie qui veulent annoncer sur le
moteur de recherche et donc nous on a
tout un mécanisme qui va territorialiser
la capacité pour certains annonceurs
d'être présent ou non présents selon les
gestion locale en fonction des agréments
qu'ils doivent avoir ou qui n'ont pas en
matière publicitaire par exemple les les
jeux en ligne en France seuls les
opérateurs agréés peuvent annoncer les
points final parce que on a mis en place
tout ce mécanisme là et par exemple sur
les jeux en ligne énormément
d'interaction avec la NJ en la matière
voilà
parce que c'est important vous avez fait
un parallèle quand j'évoquais
les pseudonymat
que vous avez dit c'est comme dans la
vraie vie quand je suis dans la rue et
que quelqu'un colporte des propos
haineux on sait pas qui c'est non c'est
pas pareil pour moi ça c'est l'anonymat
le pseudonymat c'est à dire l'anonymat
oui je le dis une fois en ligne je dis
une fois dans la rue le pseudonymat
c'est je dis au lieu de dire une fois
dans la rue je le dis 100 fois dans la
rue et voilà c'est pas pareil
alors
la question close ou est-ce qu'on reste
sur les questions alors juste je me
permettrais d'intervenir parce que
moi-même et Madame Vin Devant partir
pour des impératifs familiaux donc on ne
prend pas la fuite mais simplement avant
de partir on voudrait pouvoir répondre
sur le cyberharcèlement si c'est
assemblée en est d'accord parce qu'il
serait quand même un congru de vous
laisser à vous poser
si vous le voulez bien juste sans être
trop long sur sur ces questions je
voulais vous répondre sur la question
des chiffres que vous avez évoqué madame
je crois que c'est important ce sont des
chiffres publiques qui sont vérifiables
puisque une quarantaine de milliers de
personnes travaillent sur les enjeux de
sécurité au sein du groupe meta on a une
quinzaine de milliers de personnes qui
travaillent sur la modération
directement bien sûr nous rendons déjà
compte au régulateur de de ces de ces
ressources et avec le DSA la
transparence c'est évidemment clé donc
voilà on continuera à répondre sur ces
sujets on publie aussi les rapports de
transparence que je pourrais vous
transmettre
non c'est bon mais je vous rassure sur
le fait que la France dispose des moyens
qu'il faut pour être modéré je veux pas
vous dire combien mais il y a les moyens
qu'il faut simplement aussi une chiffre
intéressant vous le verrez c'est la
proportion de ce type de contenu c'est
un chiffre public c'est ce qu'on appelle
la prévalence internationaux technique
mais c'est de d'essayer d'évaluer
combien donc sur 10000 contenus sur une
plateforme comme Instagram 7 on fait
l'objet d'une action de modération pour
du harcèlement donc ce tout se tient
au-delà de combien de modérateurs il
faut rendre compte auprès des
régulateurs mais aussi
des élus de l'efficacité de ses moyens
parce qu'on pourrait mettre beaucoup de
moyens mais finalement il faut aussi que
ce soit efficace donc il faut avoir tous
ces chiffres qui permettent au final et
qui soient bien sûr vérifiable par le
régulateur pour pour agir donc
l'intelligence artificielle joue un rôle
de plus en plus important c'est pas un
sujet facile mais on investit beaucoup
dans ces domaines et une bonne majorité
de ces contenus peuvent être aussi
prédétés maintenant grâce à
l'intelligence artificielle donc il faut
pas se priver de
de ces outils l'autre point sur lequel
je voudrais vous répondre et alors nous
sommes regardés donc j'en profite voilà
l'anonymat c'est vrai que dans les
années 90 on avait ses parents lisait
sur Internet personne ne sait que vous
êtes un chien c'est un cartoon américain
très connu ou un chien qui servent
derrière une un ordinateur j'ai envie de
dire aujourd'hui du fait de la
coopération avec les autorités très
sincèrement et je le dis à toutes les
personnes qui pensent être anonyme sur
Internet ou du moins sur nos plateformes
vous ne l'êtes pas voilà je regarde même
la caméra vous l'avez pas ce qu'on
reçoit 25000 réquisitions par an où on
peut communiquer l'adresse email le
téléphone l'adresse IP c'est à dire que
si on nous demande on transmet
et ensuite il y a des poursuites
judiciaires à faire ça se fait donc il
est très important qu'au-delà de la
question du pseudonymat anonymat de ces
questions sur lequel il y a des vrais
débats on a rencontré des associations
qui veulent pouvoir garder une capacité
de s'exprimer en ligne sans forcément sa
vraie identité par exemple dans beaucoup
de domaines très très sensible mais je
vous rejoins totalement sur le fait que
à un moment donné on est comptable de
ces actions donc que l'on soit sous son
vrai nom sous un pseudonyme on doit
pouvoir être retrouvé par la brigade si
j'ose dire et passer en justice quand il
le faut donc ça c'est vraiment très
important je pense que nous sommes en
France nous répondons à ces requêtes
d'autres plateformes malheureusement
c'est pas forcément leur cas et j'ai
envie de dire c'est vraiment après ces
personnes qu'il faut peut-être
aujourd'hui concentrer nos moyens et le
deuxième point sur lequel je souhaite
insister c'est qu'on travaille en
collaboration sur le sujet du
cyber-harcèlement avec beaucoup
d'associations notamment y en France ni
en France anime là hotline quand on est
cyber-harcelé il est très important de
faire donc le 30 18 je regarde la caméra
aussi le 30 et c'est pas une blague
parce qu'on a revu dans des cas récents
et abominable que malheureusement ces
numéros n'avaient pas pas été
suffisamment activé par des services
administratifs parfois malheureusement
par les parents les victimes eux-mêmes
il s'agit pas de les blâmer pour ça il
s'agit de prendre le constat que il
n'est pas assez connu et aujourd'hui
donc le 30 18 doit faire l'objet de
campagne via nos ressources mais aussi
via tous les moyens possibles pour être
connus parce qu'après quand vous appelez
le 30 18 il enfance peut nous joindre et
traiter un cas particulier de
harcèlement qui malheureusement peut
avoir
échappé à la modération traditionnelle
parce qu'on est souvent dans les
discussions de harcèlement dans une
situation physique et une situation
numérique qui va un rapport du Sénat
d'ailleurs sur le sujet du harcèlement
qui est totalement édifiant qui montre
l'ampleur de ce problème et je
terminerai sur ça on est à mon avis
aujourd'hui dans une situation
comparable à la sécurité routière il y a
20 ans pendant des années on sait
malheureusement trop accumulé sur l'idée
que il pouvait avoir 10 15 20 000 morts
par an sur les routes et puis un jour le
président Chirac a dit ça suffit voilà
il a pris le problème à bras le corps il
a dit maintenant les constructeurs de
voiture les Asos les conducteurs tout le
monde je veux des résultats voilà et on
a comme ça inversé la tendance
c'est ce qu'on a besoin aujourd'hui
c'est d'un choc de société sur le
harcèlement qui nous implique évidemment
mais qui implique vraiment tous les
acteurs il faut des campagnes il faut il
faut mettre le paquet parce que ça c'est
comme ça qu'on inversera la tendance
aujourd'hui parce que traiter juste
l'aspect harcèlement physique ou
l'aspect cyberharcèlement
malheureusement on moi ça fait 10 ans
que je travaille donc je j'ai
l'impression parfois de me répéter mais
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il faut une
grande cause nationale puisqu'il y en a
tous les ans vous le savez il faut une
grande cause nationale autour du
harcèlement et je pense je crois que le
ministre de l'Éducation et d'autres
acteurs sont prêts donc allons-y voilà
je voulais pas être trop long mais c'est
un sujet qui voilà qui nous permet qui
me tient à cœur simplement c'est qu'il y
a un volet protection des citoyens dans
le texte de loi donc c'est important
d'en parler on peut se dire que tout va
bien et puis mais bon les trains 18 ça
existe depuis longtemps
moi personnellement je l'ai testé
personnellement je sais pas si efficace
que ça on n'est pas là pour faire le
débat du 118 ça marche et ça marche pas
ce qui est sorti ce qui me semble
essentiel aujourd'hui c'est de me dire
on fait un signalement on est victime de
ces bars allemands on fait un
signalement que se passe-t-il pour
protéger celui qui
est à l'origine du signalement je pense
que en fait tout le but en fait de ce
que explique Anton c'est que c'est une
chaîne de responsabilité ou les
plateformes ont bien évidemment leur
part de responsabilité mais pas que et
aujourd'hui le grand absent de ces
textes que ce soit dans le DSA mais
c'était pareil dans principe républicain
ou historiquement la loi avia les
auteurs quid des auteurs comment
sont-ils sanctionnés d'où ces
propositions de mon voisin ou de
moi-même de dire il y a des agents
sermentés via Pharos qui ont toutes les
données que vient de décrire en tonne
qu'en est-il fait et ça ça sera un
élément extrêmement important encore une
fois on pourra vous retirer des
milliards de contenus s'il y a pas un
pouvoir étatique derrière et des
sanctions qui sont menées sur les
auteurs on endigera pas le phénomène et
ça passe cette chaîne de responsabilité
aussi par le rôle des parents des
associations c'est vraiment l'ensemble
qu'il faut prendre en considération on
en a bien ce qu'on en a bien conscience
mais il faut dire et ça a été établi que
le modèle économique de vos plateformes
qui basée sur la gambette une publicité
ciblée et l'algorithme qui travaille
dans ce sens
surexpose forcément les contenus les
plus sensationnels les plus liaisons
contestables c'est démontré donc comment
je termine je termine ce que j'ai à dire
donc comment vous vous travaillez
d'abord à la transparence des
algorithmes et ce que j'appelle le
Safety ByDesign c'est à dire que on doit
se dire qu'il faut étudier presque
l'algorithme dans ses effets
potentiellement pervers en amont
avant le mettre comme un médicament sur
le marché ça c'est très important vous
ayez cette conscience aussi du modèle
économique de des plateformes pour
lesquelles vous travaillez qui génère ce
phénomène c'est quand même très
important je complète ma question et
j'espère Florence bad tricotta me
pardonnera est-ce que il reste aussi ces
questions qui sont très importantes
au lendemain de la faire Cambridge a été
cas à nos homologues
à Monsieur Collins se termine Collins
président de la Chambre la commission
culture digitale la Chambre des Communes
a fait un rapport extrêmement sévère sur
Facebook sur les failles qui ont permis
la manipulation des opinions et des
votes à sélection américaine je vous
apprends rien mais je tiens à le redire
devant ceux qui nous écoutent tout ça a
été
démontré donc nous ce qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est tirer les leçons voilà
du passé et se dire ça fait partie du
texte d'ailleurs le rapporteur on en a
parlé
à parler des ingérences étrangères
comment pouvez-vous désormais nous
garantir qu'il n'y aura plus de failles
pour permettre à des ingérences
étrangères de manipuler les opinions
et déstabiliser aussi quelque part nos
sociétés
occidentales dans leur modèle
démocratique
donc à l'avenir avec l'application du
DSA est-ce que vous avez vraiment pris
le taureau par les cordes pour faire en
sorte que
on puisse finalement contredire ce que
Francis Hogan nous a dit ici ce qu'elle
a relié à Bruxelles devant un certain
nombre de parlementaire venu du monde
entier j'y étais monsieur
et bien qu'est-ce que donc vous avez
fait vous faites vous avez fait voilà
pour vraiment maintenant mettre un terme
à ces dérives qui sont juste
inadmissibles on le dit avec force ici
parce que c'est vrai si on veut sauver
l'Internet qui nous arrive qu'il soit
pas fragmenté qui reste source de
d'échanges de progrès de connaissances
il faut prendre le tarot par les cornes
alors qu'est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
faire alors je vais tâcher d'être bref
et efficace déjà sur le modèle
économique madame j'apporterai une
respectueuse contradiction parce que
vous avez mentionné notre modèle le
chiffre d'affaires vient des annonceurs
ça ne vous empêche
les annonceurs ne veulent pas que les
réseaux sociaux soient des poubelles et
donc à chaque fois qu'il y a des
difficultés ou des articles qui parlent
de nos manquements dans un perfections
et puis des problèmes que vous décrivez
il nous appelle ils disent qu'est-ce que
vous faites parce que sinon j'arrête les
campagnes voilà comment ça se passe en
vrai voilà donc on a aucun intérêt à ce
que ce réseau se transforme comme une
poubelle bien au contraire maintenant
qu'il y ait des imperfections à régler
je vous le concerne qu'il y ait des
choses à améliorer évidemment mais je
pense qu'on ne peut pas laisser dire
qu'intra segment le modèle économique
serait basé sur la recommandation de
contenu qui serait vraiment malicieux ou
il est beau donc je préfère apporter
cette correction pour que ça soit très
clair le deuxième point sur Cambridge
Analytica alors l'expression de Monsieur
Zuckerberg elle a été aussi faite devant
le Parlement européen madame vous a pas
échappé j'imagine il est aussi regarder
assez longuement hier devant le Congrès
américain
à la recherche et à d'autres acteurs
l'autre point aussi c'est que on a pris
des mesures du coup suite à ça pour
refermer un certain nombre de partages
de données dans nos applications et tout
ceci est une littérature très documentée
donc je voudrais pas assommer
l'assistance avec ça mais il y a
beaucoup de points techniques qui ont
évolué depuis maintenant plusieurs
années sur lequel on s'est expliqué et
ça va plus rien à voir avec ça sur les
ingérences étrangères toute la partie
publicité nous avons été les premières
mettre en place une bibliothèque
publicitaire qui fait que chaque
publicité sur notre réseau est présenté
vous connaissez la cible le budget
l'émetteur le destinataire voilà très
transparent et d'ailleurs l'arcom a
publié des rapports sur la mise en
oeuvre de la loi fake news qui nous
donne plutôt crédit de nos efforts ces
dernières années et je salue aussi
l'effort de nos équipes pilotées par
Béatrice qui a qui a fait tout ceci donc
rien n'est parfait mais les choses
s'améliorent et aujourd'hui avec le DSA
on peut dire qu'on est dans une phase
aussi de mise en oeuvre qui qui laisse
façon le choix aucune entreprise de
cider donc aujourd'hui nous y sommes et
on continue voilà
ça ne vous appellera pas échapper
également qu'on publie régulièrement par
nos chercheurs aussi et on travaille
avec des autorités sur le sujet nos
rapports de transparence sur les actions
coordonnées et authentiques qui sont
publiques justement à destination et
pour alimenter les chercheurs qui
travaillent sur ce sujet on essaye de
partager un maximum de données sur ce
sur ce point concernant la bulle
algorithmique auquel vous faisiez
référence on a développé beaucoup
d'outils notamment vous pouvez choisir
dans votre fil d'actualité si vous
voulez voir le fil d'actualiser proposé
par Facebook par exemple ou celui de
votre ami de vos amis de votre grandes
amies ou alors
d'une manière purement chronologique ça
c'est des outils qui sont à disposition
justement pour éviter ces biais qui sont
à disposition des utilisateurs vous avez
également sur chaque poste et sur chaque
publicité dans les trois petits points
donc deux clics pourquoi je vois cette
publicité peut-être parce que j'ai
interagi avec telle personne peut-être
parce que j'ai aimé tel produit avec le
schéma qui essaye de vulgariser
justement à l'utilisateur comment
l'algorithme a choisi de vous présenter
ce poste ou cette publicité merci pour
vos réponses croyez bien que nous sommes
aussi exigeants et sévère avec les
autres plateformes que Facebook nous
avons une commission
merci Madame
bien alors pour le reste des questions
qui étaient très importantes également
alors on était sur peut-être toujours
l'informatique en nuage
merci pour pour vos questions
trois questions si ma mémoire est bonne
sur sur l'aspect du marché et votre
question à cet égard et sur le fait que
vous percevez les parts de marché des
Européens fondre semble aller en
contradiction avec les chiffres que j'ai
indiqué tout à l'heure pour ce qui nous
concerne nous Amazon Web Services on a
été les premiers les pionniers de ce
marché
dans le monde et en Europe et donc c'est
là aussi la raison pour laquelle on a un
certain nombre de clients avec les
clients je l'espère sont contents des
services que l'on propose c'est la
raison pour laquelle il continue à les
utiliser lorsqu'ils ne le sont plus ils
quitte nos services avec toutes les
facilités et les outils qu'on leur met à
disposition comme je l'ai rappelé dans
mon propos liminaire de manière générale
il faut pas oublier que le marché cloud
c'est un marché de naissant c'est 15% du
marché informatique global donc c'est
quand même pas non
très significatif et c'est un marché qui
reste en constante évolution plus
particulièrement en ce qui concerne
l'Europe et j'aimerais même envie de
dire la France il y a aussi un vrai
sujet sur la question de l'essor du
marché du cloud qui est lié à la
commande publique peut-être il manque
aussi il manque aussi un petit peu
d'impulsion du côté de la commande
publique qui peine à aller vers les
technologies de cloud computing qui est
un point très important il y a aussi des
sujets liés à la certitude réglementaire
de manière générale avec un certain
nombre de législations qui ont été
adoptés au niveau des États membres ou
au niveau européen sur ce sujet qui met
certains des clients dans une situation
d'incertitude sur est-ce que oui ou non
ils doivent migrer leur donner dans le
Cloud avant d'avoir l'ensemble de ces
textes qui sont appliqués et les mesures
d'application effective donc c'est un
ensemble de facteurs je pense qui qui
explique aussi les qui explique aussi
les les éléments que vous avez que vous
avez que vous avez avancé au sujet de
des questions de portabilité encore une
fois
mon propos n'était pas de dire que nous
sommes opposés aux mesures à l'inverse
j'ai bien indiqué que il y a un certain
nombre d'initiatives que nous mettons en
place depuis le début nos services ont
été conçus avec des questions
d'intérêts-parabilité et de et de
liberté de choix des clients que ce soit
par les outils utilisation en termes de
proposition des logiciels open source
comme base me semble je crois que c'est
Monsieur Gero qu'il avait rappelé être
très utile la mise à disposition des
interfaces de programmation encore
appelé API pour que toutes les sociétés
d'utilisatrices des services en nuages
et les sociétés tierces plus les
utiliser pour développer leur service
également de manière ouverte donc c'est
un autre élément qui est également très
important les standards les standards au
niveau européen qui vont probablement
émerger d'ici peu à la suite ou même par
anticipation de l'adoption du règlement
sur les données j'évoquais tout à
l'heure la question enfin le
standard le seul d'ailleurs qui existe à
ce jour qui est le fameux code swippo
standard auquel on est on est on a
déclaré un certain nombre de produits
juste pour votre détail et peut-être
pour revenir sur ce que vous disiez sur
un marché qui serait captif et qui
empêche les clients de de partir j'ai
plutôt en ce qui me concerne et ma
propre expérience des données inverse
c'est-à-dire qu'on a contribué à
l'élaboration de ce code avec une
majorité de société européenne et puis
ensuite on a fait l'effort de s'y
conformer ça a été d'ailleurs salué par
la Commission européenne mais il se
trouve que de la part de nos clients en
tout cas ils n'ont pas constaté de
barrières à au changement de prestataire
puisque depuis que nous avons déclaré
les services je n'ai à ma connaissance
pas reçu aucune question de nos clients
sur les les mesures que nous mettons en
oeuvre qui sont d'ailleurs par ailleurs
disponibles sur mon site sur le sur leur
site internet et sur les fonctionnements
du code swipo donc ça montre bien que en
tout cas de la part de nos clients
il ne voit pas à une difficulté
particulière de quitter notre
environnement pour aller chez un autre
chez un autre prestataire sur enfin la
question de la facturation du réseau je
pense qu'il y a une petite distinction à
faire vous parliez de bande passante le
réseau que j'évoquais c'était notre
réseau privé interne avant même de
pouvoir accéder à un réseau public donc
on avait un certain nombre de centres de
données j'ai évoqué la France il faut
savoir qu'en Europe on a des
architectures aussi déployés dans plein
de pays l'Espagne l'Allemagne la Suède
ou encore l'Irlande et les clients qui
transfèrent leurs données pour leurs
besoins propres comme je l'évoquais tout
à l'heure par exemple une société de qui
fait de la vidéo à la demande et bien en
fonction de des quantités de données
qu'il transfert et de la destination
vont effectivement faire une mutilation
plus ou moins intensive de ce réseau là
je parle pas du réseau classique
Internet notre sujet et pour ce cas on
estime environ que l'utilisation du
réseau en fonction d'utilisation encore
une fois peut aller entre 1% et 3% de
leur dépense annuelle en service
informatique donc c'est quand même des
sommes qui sont qui sont assez réduites
il me semble qu'il y a même une étude
qui dit que c'est en moyenne
0,0.5% d'une dépense d'un coup annuel de
qu'on appelle le run en informatique
d'une solution qui fonctionne donc on
est loin des montants des montants
invoqués de manière plus précise c'est
des facturations
avec des certains un effet de palier
enfin ou des paliers en l'occurrence et
plus on passe des paliers plus la
facturation des croix et comme j'ai
indiqué aussi dans mon propos liminaire
on fait des efforts de manière constante
pour réduire cette facturation là on a
divisé la facturation de 50% dans les
cinq dernières années
pour revenir sur vos questions et à
nouveau merci de les avoir posé je
souhaite d'aborder que même si nous
sommes au sein de la maison Google
Google cloud a un autre modèle
économique dans un modèle de service aux
entreprises qui n'a pas de lien avec le
marché publicitaire alors ça avait été
évoqué par Amazon dans ses propos
liminaires mais dans le marché de
l'informatique en nuage on paye au poids
et au temps on dit je veux telle
capacité telle puissance pendant tant de
temps après ça il est question
d'élasticité on peut rester on peut
grandir mais
intrinsèquement ça n'a rien à voir en
termes de modèles économique avec un
modèle de plateforme
ensuite vous nous aviez posé la question
de quelle proposition alors je l'avais
un peu évoqué mais lorsque deux entités
vraiment très représentatives comme le
sigref qui rassemble l'ensemble des DSI
et du secteur public et du secteur privé
il faut le souligner via cossigner cette
charte avec le sigref qui réunit un
certain nombre de fournisseurs
d'informatique en nuages au niveau
européen et encore une fois nous n'en
font nous n'en faisons pas partie voilà
quand après plusieurs années de travail
ils établissent cette charte en 10
points je pense qu'il y a de quoi s'en
inspirer pour enrichir ce texte pour
dire les choses très simplement mais je
pense que un certain nombre de
parlementaires sont pas rond
naturellement de de ces propositions
sur la question de la bande passante et
à nouveau merci à Arnaud David d'avoir
bien expliqué que il y a la partie qui
sont des réseaux propres opérateurs de
d'informatique en nuages au fournisseurs
de services c'est le choix qui a été
fait notamment chez Google dès le départ
d'investir très massivement dans ses
propres réseaux de fibres optiques qui
finissent en câble sous-marin qui vont
jusqu'à des centres de données et qui
ainsi permettent une meilleure qualité
de service là en termes d'ingénierie ce
qui recherchait par les équipes
techniques c'est d'avoir cette capacité
à monitorer la qualité de service
pardonnez-moi pour moniteur à contrôler
et à suivre cette qualité de service
tout au long du chemin de la donnée et
donc on a fait le choix de faire ces
gros investissements dans dans ce réseau
mondial et je vous parle de de dizaines
de milliards d'euros au cours des
dernières années d'investissement pour
aussi offrir à nos clients une meilleure
qualité de service et pouvoir ainsi se
différencier des autres voilà là où
d'autres secteur s'ils n'ont pas
eux-mêmes leur propre réseau s'ils n'ont
pas pu avoir ses capacités
d'investissement vont passer par des
opérateurs télécoms ils vont passer par
des opérateurs de transfert de données
et qui vont chacun pratiquer leur prix
il y a aussi le fait que si vous êtes un
acteur international comme c'est le cas
des deux entreprises qui restent encore
à la table ce soir et bien vous avez une
activité qui dépasse très largement le
champ géographique de la France et donc
nécessairement vous allez transférer ces
données à travers l'Europe à travers le
monde et donc ça va impliquer des coûts
différents si vous êtes un plus petit
fournisseur de services avec des clients
locaux ça vous coûtera forcément moins
cher puisque cette donnée sera à
transporter moins loin aussi
pratiquement que cela
il faut aussi rappeler que il n'y a pas
de fournisseurs de services qui ont
exactement la même architecture voilà
chacun a fait des choix technologiques
un peu différents alors on se rejoint
sur des questions de normes de standards
internationaux avec des équipes qui
travaillent longuement mais on a après
ça des choix d'ingénierie qui nous sont
propres
je pourrais le développer c'est pas
forcément le cas ce soir mais notamment
aussi pour des questions de consommation
énergétique de de de de coût énergétique
de nos propres services donc
nos réseaux qu'on peut avoir en propre
il y a quand on utilise un réseau
extérieur et là on nous facture un prix
nos réseaux propres on sait quel coût il
nous coûte mais si on veut pouvoir
continuer à investir et à pouvoir
optimiser cette qualité de service au
cours du temps et bien on se doit de
pouvoir continuer à offrir cette qualité
de service et puis peut-être un dernier
point sur l'interopérabilité les API
parce que Monsieur chaise est parti mais
je sais que c'est un sujet qui lui tient
prête à coeur et la question en fait de
ce qu'on appelle le multi cloud puisque
c'est une question qui est traitée aussi
au niveau européen je dois dire que en
la matière et encore une fois et je me
souviens que madame la Présidente a
commencé l'audition précédente en
parlant des 71% de parts de marché aux
trois hyperscalaires nous avons moins de
10% de ses parts de marché je tiens à
dire voilà nous sommes un challenger
nous avons des ambitions nous allons
donner les moyens de nos omissions et
d'ailleurs on a beaucoup recruté et
investi en France on a une région afin
que les données en fonction si le client
le souhaite soit localisé on est rentré
dans un projet vraiment de très grands
ampleur et très unique avec la maison
Thalès pour aller permettre à Thalès
d'offrir l'ensemble des services de
Google cloudforme au travers d'une
nouvelle société qui on l'espère un jour
aucun droit à la qualification c'est
mieux cloud mais il faut bien comprendre
que comme on est le dernier arrivé sur
le marché quand nos forces de vente vont
chez un prospect quand ils vont
prospecter le le DSI le directeur de ça
des systèmes d'information en face il
est utilisé le Cloud parce qu'il y a eu
des pionniers
iers parce que il y a eu un certain
nombre d'acteurs qui ont bougé plus vite
sur ce marché et donc par essence on est
obligé d'être interopérable parce qu'il
faut qu'on se fasse une place au milieu
des autres et que ça puisse
intercommuniquer qu'on puisse faire ces
échanges de données et cet
interopérabilité et donc c'est vraiment
par on n'a pas d'autre choix quand on
est un acteur de petite taille sur ce
marché on n'a pas d'autre choix que
faire le choix de l'interopérabilité de
l'ouverture je m'arrêterai là
peut-être sur la question des coups de
transfert pour finir alors ici on est
dans une retransmission télévisée et
puis devant des concurrents directs donc
il y a un certain nombre de données
qu'on ne peut pas partager mais soyez
bien persuadés et j'espère que ce sera
dans le prochain rapport de loto de la
concurrence que nous avons partagé dans
manière confidentielle avec l'Autorité
de la concurrence ce type de données de
manière très précise je m’arrêterai là
par contre
oui peut-être d'un mot madame la
Présidente pour répondre à la conclusion
la dernière question qui était posée sur
les sur les places de marché de produits
par madame la sénatrice pour confirmer
qu'effectivement notre place de marché
celle d'Amazon et bien sûr soumise pour
ce qui concerne les produits vendus en
France aux droits français sous le
contrôle vigilant des autorités
françaises la DGCCRF pour ne pas la
nommer et du juge français simplement le
droit français lui-même est une
combinaison de règles qui sont d'origine
strictement nationale et de textes qui
font partie du droit français
aujourd'hui mais qui sont issus de la
transposition d'un exercice tout à fait
similaire à celui auquel vous allez vous
livrer aujourd'hui de texte européen
donc il y a un ensemble de textes la
directive sur le commerce en ligne de
2003 et d'autres textes qui ont qui sont
d'origine plus récente qui vise
justement à
rehausser les standards pour que le
droit français soit à la fois très
protecteur pour les consommateurs et
soit également très alignés sur les
droits de ses voisins pour citer un ou
deux exemples de textes extrêmement
récents le paquet sur les produits et
puis le règlement sur la mutualisation
des normes techniques qui ont été qui
ont été transposés en droit français
très récemment donc voilà je confirme
que les produits que nous vendons sont
soumis aux droits français dans tous sa
plénitude
bien mes chers collègues je crois que
nous avons eu une longue séance riche de
questions de de réponse en tout cas ce
que je voulais souligner par rapport à
votre remarque sur 2015 vous positionnez
pour le développement du marché européen
numérique c'est vrai que c'est un marché
profond et durable 500 millions de de
consommateurs mais je crois que nous
sommes passés dans une autre
ère nous avons pris conscience que nous
dépendions tous de cet écosystème et que
il n'était pas sans sans défaut et qu'il
fallait corriger
les comment dire je des conditions de
juste concurrence des effets pervers sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est pas une jungle
Internet ne peut pas une jungle c'était
merdier qui le disait lui-même le fond
le cofondateur du web dans le lendemain
de l'affaire Cambridge et que si nous
voulons un monde soutenable en matière
de nouvelles technologies et qu'elles
puissent être des sources de progrès il
faut que ce monde soit parfaitement
régulé et sécurisé aujourd'hui c'est une
responsabilité que tous les acteurs
quels qu'ils soient européens comme
extraordinaires doivent partager
c'est un sujet de très très grande
importance et je pense qu'on est
vraiment à la croisée des chemins voilà
et donc l'Europe développe une politique
beaucoup plus stratégique désormais ça
nous a pas échappé sous l'impulsion du
commissaire breton et l'ensemble des
textes de règlement qui se succèdent
c'est bien pour corriger un petit peu
voilà cette défaillance pendant des
années où ce monde là finalement n'a pas
du tout été
régulée et s'est développé et d'ailleurs
je pense que ça servira tout comme le
rgpd quelque part un peu des talons d'or
pour le pour le monde et que on nous
observe aussi et donc ça son importance
voilà
sur ces mots
je voulais vous remercier encore une
fois d'être venu ça lui mon collègue
Cora Cora porteur avec Patrick chaise et
puis mes collègues ainsi que nos
administrateurs